watched online unedited recording will
be available on the committee's website
not go well this is our participating
video conference and one-time exception
some senators including the chairman are
participating by videoconference
senators we've been advised may remove
their masks talking to the microphone
when they're in the hearing room as
they're six feet apart I'm grateful to
the Rules Committee sergeant at arms the
press gallery the architect of the
Capitol the Capitol police committee
staff Chun Czech and Evan Griffiths all
for their hard work to keep us safe at
our hearing last Thursday I said that
all roads back to work and back to
school run through testing and that what
our country has done so far on testing
is impressive but not nearly enough over
the weekend Senator Schumer the
Democratic leader was nice enough to put
out a tweet quoting a half of what I
said you left out the other half the
impressive part so let me say again what
I meant by that when I said impressive
I meant that according to Johns Hopkins
University study the United States has
tested over 9 million Americans fork
over 19 as twice as many as any other
country we don't know what China has
done and it's more per capita than most
countries including South Korea which
many members of our committee had cited
as an example of a country that had
tested well according to dr. deborah
birx the United States will double
testing in the month of Wei month of May
which should get us up to about 10
million tests conducted now here's what
I mean by impressive here in Tennessee
where I am today
first anyone who's sick first responder
or health care worker can get tested our
governor Bill Lee is also testing every
prisoner every resident staff member in
a nursing home
he's offered weekend thrived through
testing he's done specific outreach for
testing to low-income communities at
Tennessee and can get a free test at the
local Public Health Department
the governor's slogan is if in doubt get
a test no matter least sent his testing
goals inmate
federal government is every state has
done federal government is helping him
make sure that he has enough supplies in
case he has trouble getting them through
labs and the other commercial sources as
a result our state has tested about 4%
of the population governor hopes to
increase that by 7% in May that's one of
the best in the country this impressive
level of testing is sufficient we
believe to begin phase one of going back
to work which as I said last week it's
not nearly enough to provide confidence
to 31,000 students and faculty members
but we hope will show up at the
University of Tennessee campus in August
when school starts last week I talked
with UT Knoxville Chancellor Don D
Plowman about that we said what would
persuade those 31,000 students as well
as the 50 million K through 12 students
in the country and the other 5,000
University students what will persuade
them to go back to campus in August
that's where the new shark tank comes in
dr. Collins at the National Institutes
of Health calls it red X we had our
hearing about that on Thursday it's a
really remarkable scientific exercise to
take a few early stage concepts that are
swimming around and what we call that
competitive shark tank and see if dr.
Collins and his associates can find a
few new technologies to create millions
of new tests that will scale up rapidly
and make it more likely that students
will go back to school in August for
example the FDA authorized last week its
first diagnostic tests using saliva that
a person provides at home instead of a
nose swab or blood it authorized its
first antigen test we're hearing a lot
about those like the ones used for flu
or strep throat which involves the
swabbing of a nose and you can get the
result in just a few minutes another
proposal not yet approved is to put in
your mouth as sort of lollypop sponge
take a photo of that with your cell
phone and send that to your doctor if it
lights up you're positive
or the university might send that saliva
lollipop to a nearby laboratory which
could be a gene sequencing laboratory
which can deal with thousands of those
samples overnight that same process
could occur and a middle stuart could
occur in a factory of course anyone
testing negative one day can test
positive the next but such widespread
screening of entire campuses schools or
places of work will help identify those
who are sick trace down those who are
exposed and that in turn should help
persuade the rest of us to go back to
school and back to work in addition to
more testing I expect doctor foul chief
talked to us about additional treatments
that will be available to reduce the
risk of death and the administration's
plan to do something that our country
has never done before which is to start
manufacturing a vaccine before it
actually has been proven to work in
order to speed up the result in case it
does work those vaccines those
treatments are the ultimate solution but
until we have them all roads back to
work and school go through testing the
more tests we conduct the better we can
identify those who are sick and exposed
and we can quarantine the sick and
exposed instead of trying to quarantine
the whole country now in my opinion this
require millions of new tests many from
new technologies some of these will fail
well we only need a few successes to get
where we want to go that's why I said on
Thursday that what our country had done
so far in testing is impressive but not
nearly enough first squeeze all the
tests we can out of current technologies
next try to find new technologies to
help us contain the disease and persuade
us to go back to work now one other
thing this is a bipartisan hearing to
examine how well we're preparing to go
safely back to work in to school and to
determine what else we need to do in the
United States Senate such an exercise
sometimes encourages finger-pointing
before we
too much time finger-pointing I'd like
to suggest that almost all of us the
United States and almost every country
so far as I can tell
underestimated this virus underestimated
how contagious it would be
underestimated house how it can travel
silently in people without symptoms to
infect other people now it can be
especially deadly for certain segments
of our population the elderly those with
pre-existing conditions minority
populations let me go back to the March
3rd hearing that we had in our committee
on coronavirus six weeks after the first
case was discovered in the United States
a day when only two deaths were recorded
in this country I read at that hearing
this paragraph from the New York Times
two days earlier on March the first they
reported this much about the corona
virus remains unclear times reported and
it's far from certain this is March 3rd
that March 1 that that the outbreak will
reach severe proportions in the United
States or affect many regions at once
with its top-notch scientists modern
hospitals and sprawling public health
infrastructure most experts agree United
States is among the country's best
prepared to prevent or manage such an
epidemic was the New York Times on March
1 a lot of effort has gone into trying
to make our country well-prepared over
the last 20 years for president several
congresses in response to 9/11 bird flu
Katrina Ebola h1n1 MERS past nine major
laws that try to help get this country
ready or what we're going through today
these laws stood up the strategic
national stockpile created an assistant
secretary for preparedness it created
incentives for the development of
vaccines and and medicines that we're
using today strengthen the Centers for
Disease Control created our de thanks to
the leadership of Senator blunt
senator Murray for five straight years
we've significantly increased funding
for the National Institutes of Health
all this was part of a shared goal
Democrats Republicans or presidents
several congresses to try to get ready
for what we're going through today
whether it was known like anthrax or
unknown like Koba 19 but despite all
that effort even the experts
underestimated covin 19 this hearing is
about how we improve our response to
this virus as well is the next during
the oversight hearing I also intend to
focus on as I just said the next
pandemic which we know is coming what
can we learn from this one to be ready
for the next one can we what can we
learn from the fast-tracking of vaccines
and treatments that we're about to hear
about that will make it even faster than
next time how can we keep hospitals and
states from selling off protective
equipment when their budget gets tight
how can we make sure Congress knows our
share of the funding responsibilities
how do we provide enough extra hospital
beds without without canceling elective
surgery hurting other patients and
bankrupting hospitals whose job should
it be the coordinate supply lines so
that protective equipment and supplies
get where they're supposed to go when
they're supposed to go what's the best
way to manage the stockpile my preacher
once said I'm not worried about what you
do on Sunday it's the rest of the week
that concerns me
I'm afraid that during the rest of the
week between pandemics we relaxed our
focus on preparedness we become
preoccupied with other important things
our collective memory is short just
three months ago this country was
preoccupied with impeaching the
president now that seems like ancient
Roman history now while this crisis has
our full attention I believe we should
put into law this year whatever
improvements need to be made to be well
prepared for the next endeavor if there
is to be finger-pointing hope they're
pointed in that direction
we're fortunate today to have four
distinguished witnesses we're at the
heart of the response the coronavirus
were grateful for their service to our
country
I've asked them each to summarize their
remarks in five minutes then we'll have
five minute round of questions from each
senator I've agreed we'll end our
hearing about 12:30 after we have a full
round of questions every senator will
have a chance to have his or her five
minutes senator Murray will then have an
opportunity to ask the last question or
to close the hearing and I will then
close the hearing there will be other
hearings to follow this hearing like
last Thursday's hearings and Senators
may submit their questions in writing
within the next ten days staying at home
indefinitely is not the solution to this
pandemic there is not enough money
available to help all those hurt by a
closed economy all roads back to work
and back to school lead through testing
tracking isolation treatment and
vaccines
this requires widespread testing
millions more tests created mostly by
new technologies to identify those who
are sick and who've been exposed so they
can be quarantined and by containing the
disease in this way you have the rest of
America and enough confidence to go back
to working school for the near-term help
make sure those 31,000 UT students and
faculty members show up in August we
need widespread testing millions more
tests created mostly by new technologies
who identified those who are sick who
have been exposed so they can be
quarantined by containing the disease in
this way you have the rest of America
enough confidence to go back to work and
back to school
senator Murray well thank you very much
mr. chairman my thoughts are with you
and your team right now as you try to
navigate the same challenge so many in
our country are worried about
we all wish your staff member a speedy
recovery and as everyone works to take
appropriate safety precautions today I'd
like to thank not
they are witnesses for joining us today
but also our committee staff were
working to set up a safe format for
members and witnesses and the public to
participate in this hearing remotely
families across the country are counting
on us for the truth about the Cova 19
pandemic especially since it is clear
they will not get it from presidents not
truth is essential so people have the
facts so they can make decisions for
themselves and their families and their
communities lives are at stake if the
president isn't telling the truth we
must and our witnesses must and we're
counting on you today and families need
us to take this opportunity to dig into
the facts about where things did go
wrong so we can finally get them on
track because the Trump administration's
response to this public health emergency
so far has been a disaster on its own
delays missteps have put us way behind
where we need to be on diagnostic tests
and allowed inaccurate antibody tests to
flood the market corruption and
political interference have impeded
efforts to secure desperately needed
personal protective equipment and
promoted dangerous unproven treatments
and we recently learned that after
experts at the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention spent weeks
developing a detailed guide to help our
communities understand how to safely
reopen when the time comes the Trump
administration tossed it in the trash
bin for being too prescriptive but this
is far from the first time this
administration has silenced experts who
were doing their job and putting public
health first the fact of the matter is
President Trump has been more focused on
fighting against the truth than fighting
this virus and Americans have sadly paid
the price
since this committee last heard from
these witnesses on March 3rd we have
seen over 900 deaths in my home state of
Washington over 80
thousand deaths nationally and the
numbers continue to climb still
president Trump is trying to ignore the
facts and ignore the experts who's been
very clear we are nowhere close to where
we need to be to reopen safely my hope
today is that we can cut through this
and have a serious discussion about what
is needed to safely open how close we
are as a country to meeting those needs
and how we actually get there
one thing that's abundantly clear we
need dramatically more testing it is
unacceptable we still don't have a
national strategic plan to make sure
testing is free fast and everywhere that
is why I thought to make sure our last
Kovan 19 package included an initial 25
billion dollars testing fund and a
requirement that the administration
submit a plan by May 24th and when I say
a plan I don't mean a PR plan I mean a
plan with specific timelines and numeric
goals for supply and funding needs one
that actually addresses the issues were
seeing on testing capacity and
distribution and disparities and
building out our public health system
and makes clear to states and tribes and
employers and the American people what
they can expect and what the
administration will do to keep Americans
safe but testing alone won't be enough
to reopen our country we still need far
more personal protective equipment that
has been available for our health care
workers on the frontlines and we will
need far more for other workers as we
reopen so we desperately need this
administration to step up and get that
equipment to states who are doing
everything in their power to purchase
supplies but simply cannot get nearly
enough because the reality is unlike
states the federal government has the
tools to actually fix the problem if
only the administration would use them
and we also need that equipment to
actually work and for the FDA to act
promptly if it does not not weeks later
when people may have already been
exposed and just as importantly we can't
expect people to go back to work or to
restaurants or to confidently send their
kids to school if there isn't clear
detailed guidance about how to do that
safely schools from early childhood
through college need to know how to keep
their students their staff and their
educators safe when should they wear
masks how do you run a school cafeteria
or a school bus
if they can't reopen classrooms schools
and families need to know we are working
to ensure every student gets an
education tools like online learning can
only get us so far if we don't address
the digital divide that so that every
student can access that and even then
there will be learning loss that could
deepen existing educational disparities
among low-income students students with
disabilities English language learners
and other vulnerable populations if we
don't make sure they get equal access to
resources and support and of course
schools aren't the only workplaces we've
got to be thinking about we need to make
sure that industries across the country
know how to safely reopen and that
people know their workplace is safe
secretary Scalia needs to stop dragging
his feet and do his job and have the
Department of Labor set forward a rule
that makes clear worker safety is not
optional mr. Chairman I hope this
committee can hear about those critical
issues from Secretary Scalia and
secretary give us as well as other
experts in the space in the days ahead
and this is especially important to
protect workers and residents at our
nursing homes and other congregate care
facilities where we've seen some of the
most deadly outbreaks and it's the rash
of outbreaks at meatpacking plants shows
this isn't just an issue for the health
care industry it is an issue for
everyone and just as we need a plan
before we can start to reopen we also
need a plan well before we have a safe
and effective vaccine to guarantee that
we can quickly produce and distribute it
on a global scale and make it free and
available for everyone
so I'll be asking about our progress on
those issues today today safely
reopening our country may be a ways off
and the administration's planning may be
way behind but there's still a lot that
Congress needs to do there isn't time to
spare some including the White House say
we've already provided enough economic
relief my question to them is what good
is a bridge that only gets you to the
middle of the river we don't need to
wait around to see if people need more
help we know they do we need to work
quickly on another aggressive relief
package and we need to make sure our
priorities in that bill are protecting
our workers our students and our
families and addressing this public
health crisis not bailing out
corporations or protecting big business
from accountability people across the
country are doing their part they are
washing their hands and wearing masks
and social distancing and staying home
they need their government to do its
part too they need leadership they need
a plan they need honesty and they need
it now before we reopen so they can rest
assured that we are doing things safely
and confidently with their health and
well-being as a top priority Thank You
mr. chairman
just keeping it's an important hearing
and I know lots of people may be
watching it for the first time if they
are I hope they noticed that we have 23
members of this committee I believe one
more republican than democrat we have
some very strong views but we're able to
work together and to express those views
and respect each other and our witnesses
and that and a big part of that goes to
Senator Murray and her staff so thank
you for that each witness will have up
to five minutes to give his his
testimony thank you for making an
exception at agreeing to testify by
video because of these unusual
circumstances and thank you for what
you're doing for our country our first
with witnesses dr. Anthony Falchi a he's
director of the National Institutes of
Allergy and Infectious Diseases
at the National Institutes of Health
he's held that positions for not since
1980
or which meant using biased six
presidents and worked on hiv/aids
influenza malaria Ebola and other
infectious infectious diseases he was
involved in treating Ebola patients at
NIH and also worked on vaccine trials
for Ebola next we'll hear from dr.
Robert Redfield he's director of the US
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention which has its headquarters in
Atlanta more than 30 years he's been
involved with clinical research related
to chronic human viral infections
infections diseases especially HIV he
was the founding director of the
department of retroviral research for
the US military's HIV research program
he spent 20 years with the US Army
Medical Corps third Admiral Brett
yeo-hwa yeo-hwa Admiral is assistant
secretary for health at the US
Department of Health and Human Services
that puts him in charge of development
of public health policy recommendations
he's taken on the responsibility for
coordinating testing and focused on the
increasing number of tests that we can
do with the existing technology his
federal service includes a variety of
activities with our Defense Department
and Advanced Research Threat Reduction
he was part of a blue-ribbon panel who
reformed the US veteran's health system
and finally we will hear from dr. Steven
hon he's Commissioner of the Food and
Drug Administration for joining FDA he
was the chief medical Executive the
University of Texas MD Anderson Cancer
Center he was chair of the department of
radiation oncology at the University of
Pennsylvania was a senior investigator
at the National Institutes of Health his
commander of the US Public Health
Service commissioned Corps
from 2025 now we'll ask each of our
witnesses to summarize their remarks in
five minutes following that each senator
will have five minutes for questions and
answers in order of seniority
dr.
let's begin with you welcome thank you
very much mr. chairman ranking member
Murray and members of the committee
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to discuss with you today the role the
National Institutes of Health in
research addressing cope at 19 a
strategic plan that we have is fourfold
one to improve our fundamental knowledge
of the virus and the disease it causes
next to develop new point of care
Diagnostics next to characterize and
test therapeutics and finally develop
safe and effective vaccines first with
regard to Diagnostics as you probably
heard from dr. Francis Collins last
Thursday the NIH has developed a rapid
acceleration of Diagnostics program
called red X with an award to that
specific program up to a half a billion
dollars to support the development of
copán 19 Diagnostics it is a national
call the innovative technologies that
will be evaluated in a shark tank like
selection process to get to either
success or failure rapidly moving on to
therapeutics I'll talk a bit about the
rim decid be a success antiviral in a
moment but let me emphasize that there
are a number of broad-spectrum
antivirals that are in various stages of
testing in addition we will be looking
at convalescent plasma which is plasma
from individuals we've recovered from
kovat 19 to be used in passive transfer
either in prevention or treatment in
addition hyper immune globulin which can
be used as a gamma globulin shot we'll
be looking at repurposed drugs as well
as immune based therapies and host
modifiers and finally monoclonal
antibodies let me take a moment to
describe the renessa via the siva
control randomized trial which was done
internationally with a power of bor than
a thousand individuals and sites
throughout the world it was in
hospitalized patients with lung disease
the endpoint was primarily time to
recover it
the result was statistically significant
but really modest and we must remember
it was only a modest result showing that
the drug made a 31% faster time the
recovery we hope to build on this modest
success with combinations of drugs and
been a drugs moving on to vaccines there
are at least eight candidate Copa 19
vaccines in clinical development the NIH
has been collaborating with a number of
pharmaceutical companies at various
stages of development I will describe
one very briefly which is not the only
one but one that we have been involved
in heavily developing with more Danner
it's a messenger RNA platform you might
recall in this committee that in January
of this year I said that it would take
about one year to 18 months if we were
successful in developing a vaccine the
NIH trial moved very quickly on January
10th the sequence was known On January
the 11th the vaccine research sentiment
to develop a plan on the 14th of January
we officially started the vaccine
development sixty two days later we are
now in Phase one clinical trial with the
two doses already fully enrolled there
will be animal safety the phase one will
directly go into Phase two three in late
spring and early summer and if we are
successful we hope to know that in the
late fall and early winter there are
some important issues however in covert
19 vaccine development we have many
candidates at hope to have multiple
winners in other words its multiple
shots on goal this will be important
because this would be good for global
availability if we have more than one
successful candidate we also as the
chairman mentioned will be producing
vaccine at risk which means we'll be
investigating considerable resources in
developing doses even before we know any
given candidate or candidates work I
must warn that there's also the
possibility of negative consequences
where certain vaccines can actually
enhance the negative effect of the
infection the big unknown
efficacy will it be present or absence
and how durable will it be and finally I
want to mention the NIH has launched a
public-private partnership called
accelerating Cova 19 the reputed
interventions and vaccines the purpose
of that is to prioritize and accelerate
clinical evaluation of therapeutic
candidates with near-term potential
hopefully our research efforts together
with the other public health efforts
will get us quickly to an end to this
terrible ordeal that we are all going
through thank you very much happy to
answer questions later
thank you dr. edsen well good morning
chairman Alexander and ranking member
Murray and members of the committee our
nation is confronting the most serious
public health crisis in more than a
century yet we're not defenseless we
have powerful tools to fight the
sentiment imme we have tried and true
effective public health interventions
such as early case identification
isolation and contact tracing combined
with important mitigation strategy
include social distancing frequent
hand-washing with base covering these
public health tools have and will
continue to slow the spread of covered
19 I preached the opportunity this
morning to provide a brief overview of
some of CDC's ongoing work in response
to Cove at night CDC has been working
24/7 to combat the endemic CDC's
Emergency Operations Center is
supporting state tribal local and
territorial of the Gulf partners in
building core capabilities particularly
work force laboratory and data and
predictive analytics epidemiologists are
conducting surveillance for coab in
nineteen as well as conducting health
system surveillance community mitigation
teams are providing guidance on
infection control and contact tracing
and our laboratory experts or
performance or on serological testing to
better define the extent of asymptomatic
populations as local leadership makes
decisions to reopen they'll require
varying degrees of federal support each
location will be different and will face
unique circumstances CDC has conducted a
state-by-state assess
of public health testing capacity and
key contact tracing capacity as well as
surge plans CDC is providing technical
assistance and funding to the states
provided through the Supplemental cares
Act in the Paycheck protection program
and health care Enhancement we're
working directly with the state public
health leaders to define their needs for
testing and testing devices supplies and
manpower surveillance data collection
and reporting contact tracing infection
control and outbreak investigation I
want to spend a moment to focus on
several key elements first testing rapid
extensive and widely available timely
testing is essential for reopening
America CDC's role in testing continues
to support diagnosis and contact tracing
surveillance and outbreak when we work
with the public health partners to
define their particular esting strategy
their jurisdiction animal drive will
address the testing components of the
response to greater detail contact
tracing increasing state tribal local
territorial contact tracing capacity is
critical it's a critical part to stop
the change the transmission and prevent
the occurrence of sustained community
transmission CDC's role is to provide
technical training assistance and
support to the states as they hire and
build a work force necessary to be fully
prepared to effectively respond to the
public health challenges posed by the
ongoing Kobin pandemic this will be an
expansive effort surveillance our
nation's surveillance program is built
on a combination assistance including
existent existing syndromic influenza
and respiratory viral disease
surveillance systems have been combined
with commercial and research lab
platforms and our case reporting form
system CDC's adapting these and
optimizing it to have a surveillance
system in response to cope in nineteen
importantly in light of the significant
occurrence of asymptomatic infection the
surveillance for asymptomatic infection
becomes an important public health tool
early case identification EDC is working
with each public health jurisdiction to
develop a perspective surveillance
program to include active surveillance
among those that are most vulnerable
such as individuals in long-term care
facilities inner-city clinics and
homeless shelters we need to rebuild our
nation's public health infrastructure
and its public health laboratory
resilience and our nation's public
health workforce now is the time to put
it in place for the generations to come
not only for the public health system
that our nation needs but for the public
health system our nation deserves before
I close I want to recognize the tireless
commitment the dedicated CDC staff who
deployed to every corner of this nation
to fight kovat 19 more than 4,000
employees have deployed here and
globally science and data continue with
technical expertise and public source
service you mean the backbone of CDC's
contributions to the US response I
extend my serious gratitude to the
health care workers and the frontlines
as well as their family and the
essential emergency personnel as well as
the American people to say thank you for
adhering to the stay on home guidelines
and protecting the most vulnerable it's
important to emphasize that we're not
out of the woods yet
battle contends only months but we are
more prepared we need to stay vigilant
with social distancing it remains an
imperative we are a resilient nation and
I am confident that we will emerge from
this pandemic longer together thank you
thank you dr. Redfield Admiral welcome
here to provide you with an update on
the nation's progress in testing for
kovat 19 on March 12th secretary azar
requested that I lead the kovat 19
testing efforts within HHS including
oversight and coordination of the FDA
and CDC with regard to testing since
then the nation has performed more than
nine-million copa de 19 tap a number far
greater than any other country and
double the per-capita tests performed to
date in South Korea to reach this point
we implemented a phase
approach to meat testing needs during
mitigation and now during phase one
reopening of America beginning March
20th we pioneer 241 community-based
drive-through testing sites in locations
prioritized by the CDC these sites have
been a profound success testing over
167,000 high-risk individuals and
demonstrating a prototype that is being
duplicated multifold in nearly every
state next the administration leveraged
trusted retailers including CVS Rite Aid
Walgreens Walmart Kroger and health Mart
who are now providing testing at 240
locations in 33 states 69% of which are
in communities with moderate to high
social vulnerability to meet the need
for collection supplies like swabs and
media tubes we first secured the global
supply chain through a military air
bridge we worked directly with
manufacturers to increase domestic
production we collaborated with the
private sector and the FDA to validate
multiple swab and media types that
vastly expanded supplies while
minimizing the need for PPE finally we
used title 3 of the defense production
act to further invest in domestic
manufacturing to prepare us for
reopening to support the need for
surveillance testing during reopening on
April 27th we issued a new testing
framework that also prioritized testing
for persons without symptoms who are
prioritized by health department's or
clinicians for any reason including
screening of asymptomatic individuals
according to state and local plan next
our federal multidisciplinary team
conducted multiple calls with leadership
from each state to set state specific
testing objectives
collectively states and territories
established an overall goal to perform
12.9 million tests over the next four
weeks the federal government is able to
and will support the achievement of this
goal specifically the federal government
is shipping to States
twelve point nine million swabs and over
nine point seven
million tubes of media in May alone last
month we also detailed the location and
capacity of every lab machine in every
state that could potentially run kovat
19 assays and our team has worked with
test suppliers to match reagents to
these machine looking forward between
now and the end of 2020 the federal
government will procure over 135 million
swabs and 132 million tubes of media and
distribute these to states as requested
to supplement the now robust commercial
supply we anticipate marked increases in
current tests as well as a dramatic
expansion of new point-of-care tests
like the first in-class quenelle antigen
test authorized by the FDA just last
Friday quenelle anticipates being able
to distribute 300,000 tests per day
within just a few weeks so by September
taking every aspect of development
authorization manufacturing and supply
chain into consideration we project that
our nation will be capable of performing
at least 40 to 50 million tests per
month if needed at that time and if new
technologies are authorized like whole
genome sequencing approaches or any
novel solutions uncovered by NIH s new
diagnostics initiative that number will
be much higher finally I want to
acknowledge and express my heartfelt
gratitude to the officers of the US
Public Health Service commissioned Corps
the uniformed service I am honored to
lead 3471 men and women who have
deployed in support of this pandemic on
the cruise ship in Japan to our military
bases repatriating American to our
community-based testing sites and
International Airport to FEMA and our
task forces two nursing facilities
including King County Washington and two
field hospitals and hard-hit communities
across our nation I thank each and every
one of these officers and their families
and on their behalf I thank the members
of this committee for supporting our
training needs and the establishment of
a Ready Reserve to supplement our ranks
in future national emergencies thank you
for the opportunity to provide these
remarks
Thank You Admiral juruá and now dr.
Stephen Hahn our fourth and final
witness chairman Alexander ranking
member marianm members of the committee
thank you for inviting me to participate
in this hearing today I first want to
start by thanking the American people
for their incredible efforts at
mitigation and extend my condolences to
those who have lost loved ones from day
one of this pandemic the 18,000 FDA
employees are just incredible scientists
doctors and nurses have taken an active
role in the all of government response
to this pandemic FDA has worked to
facilitate the development of medical
countermeasures to diagnose treat and
prevent over nineteen we've worked
closely with laboratories manufacturers
academia product developers our federal
partners and companies companies that
don't even make medical products but
want to pitch in for example by making
hand sanitizer personal protective
equipment and ventilators every decision
we have made have been driven by data
with the goal of protecting the health
of the American people in a public
health emergency however our response
has balanced the urgent need to make
medical products available with the
provision of a level of oversight that
helps ensure the safety and
effectiveness of those medical products
I'd like to take a few minutes to tell
you what FDA is doing to help the
country at this point and which Marika's
shows is safe to return to work in to
spool it starts with testing as others
have mentioned FDA has worked with more
than 500 developers who have or said
they will be submitting emergency use
authorization requests for over 19 tests
this includes some newer technologies
that not that heretofore have not been
used as part of diagnostic tests in
response to a pandemic we have issued 92
individual emergency use authorization
for test kit manufacturers and
laboratories and we've been informed by
more than 250 laboratories they've begun
testing under the regulatory flexibility
as we outlined in mark
we are conducting rolling reviews of you
a submissions so that we can quickly
authorize tests in which the data
support in a public health emergency the
accuracy of diagnostic tests is
important not only for the individual
patient but for the patient at large for
the public at large FDA is helping to
ensure the availability of tests that
are providing accurate answers we are
also monitoring the marketplace for
fraudulent tests and are taking
appropriate action to protect the public
health and we are working to provide
more clarity about which tests have been
reviewed and authorized by FDA and which
have not seer logic tests will play a
role in our recovery
unlike diagnostic tests which detect the
presence of the virus serologic test--
measure the amount of antibodies or
protein present in the blood when the
body is responding to an infection lake
toba 19 these tell tests can help
identify individuals who can overcome an
infection we've developed an immune
response we will continue working with
labs manufacturers and across the
government to find a balance between the
assurance that an antibody test is
accurate and timely access to such tests
of course the way we will eventually
beat this virus is with a vaccine an FDA
is working closely with our federal
partners including the NIH tested I mean
vaccine developers manufacturers and
experts across the globe we intend to
use our regulatory flexibility to help
ensure the most ensure efficient
development of a safe and effective
vaccine to prevent kovat 19 until a
preventive vaccine is approved however
we need medical products to bridge the
gap FDA has been working for several
months to facilitate the development and
availability of therapeutics as
expeditiously as possible and we've
created an emergency program for this
acceleration called the corona treatment
coronavirus treatment acceleration
program or C tab we have reassigned
staff to work with urgency to review
requests from companies scientist
doctors who are developing therapies and
we're using every available Authority
and register regulatory flexibility
that's appropriate to facilitate the
development of safe and effective
products to treat Co vat19
right if there are pewter carries are
being evaluated as mentioned by dr.
vouching others including new therapies
as well as convalescent Plaza
hyperemia globulin and monoclonal
antibodies as dr. Fauci also mentioned
we recently announced the positive
results of the NIAID trial a tram
disappear and issued an EU a for the
treatment of hospitalized patients with
Koba 19:00 two other promising
treatments that I mentioned are the
antibody rich products convalescent
plasma and high cream globulin and I am
certainly willing to go into more detail
if members of this committee had
questioned questions about this we are
working very aggressively and closely
with stakeholders to the do to
facilitate the development of monoclonal
antibodies which if shown to be safe and
effective could act as a bridge therapy
to the development of vaccine we
recognize that developing vaccines and
therapies need to go hand-in-hand with
ensuring that there will be sufficient
supplies for our companies for our
country so we're also working with
manufacturers to make sure that this
supply chain is robust mr. chairman
ranking member members of the committee
please know that an FDA of a dedicated
team of some of the nation's finest
scientists health care providers and
public health professionals we are
guided by science and data and we won't
let up until we facilitate the
development of products that our nation
needs to get back to work I look forward
to your questions
thank you dr. Hahn and thanks to all
four of you for your expertise for your
dedication to our country and your hard
work will now begin around a five-minute
questions from each senator on the
committee alternating between
Republicans Democrats each senator has
if you're a videoconference you have a
little time clock at the bottom and I
would ask you to try to stay within five
minutes for your questions and answers I
will start I've got a question for dr.
ouchy and then Admiral geraw doctor
let's look down the road three months
there will be about 5,000 campuses
across the country trying to welcome 20
million college students
100,000 public schools welcoming 50
million students what would you say to
the Chancellor of the University of
Tennessee Knoxville or the President or
the principal of a public school about
how to persuade parents and students to
return to school in August let's start
with treatments and vaccines first dr.
falchion if you could save about half of
my five minutes for Edwin geraw for
testing I would appreciate thank you
very much mr. chairman
well I would be very realistic with the
Chancellor and tell him that when we're
thinking in terms it's a hurt in this
case I would tell her I'm sorry sir that
in this case that the idea of having
treatments available or a vaccine to
facilitate the re-entry of students into
the fall term would be something that
would be a bit of a bridge too far as I
mentioned the drug that has shown some
degree of of efficacy was modest and it
was in hospitalized patients not yet or
maybe ever to be used either yet as
prophylaxis or treatment so if the issue
is that the young individuals who be
going back to school would like to have
some comfort and that there's a
treatment probably the thing that would
be closest to utilization then would
likely be passive transfer of
convalescent serum but we're really not
talking about necessarily treating a
student who gets ill but how the student
will feel safe and going back to school
if this were a situation where we had a
vaccine that would really be the end of
that issue in a positive way but as I
mentioned in my opening remarks even at
the top speed we're going we don't see a
vaccine playing in the ability of
individuals to get back to school
this turn what they really want is to
know if they are safe and that's the
question that have to be do with what we
discussed earlier about testing so I'm
about halfway through the remarks I'd
like to just pass the baton to Admiral
jawad who would address the
the question of the availability of
testing and what role that might play in
returning to school thank you sir thank
you thank you dr. Fazzio Deborah would
your why you you said that while we're
doing about 10 million tests this month
that we might be as high as 40 or 50
million by September and and a month
which is a significant increase so if
I'm Chancellor of the University of
Tennessee could I develop a strategy
where I'd say to all my students we have
for example an antigen test which is
quick and easy you want everybody on
campus to come by and take it once
before you begin school that would at
least let everybody know that on that
day we've isolated anybody who's
positive and then we can continue to
monitor is that strategy possible in
August and September so so thank you mr.
chairman and I may reserve 20 seconds
for dr. Redfield as well the strategy
that's going to be employed really
depends heavily on what's the community
spread at that time if there's almost no
community spread your strategy will be
different if there's high community
stress spread it will also be different
but yes technically we will have the
ability and your Chancellor will have
the ability we expect there to be 25 to
30 million point-of-care tests per month
available is certainly possible to test
all of the students or it is much more
likely that there would be a
surveillance strategy done where you may
test some of the students at different
times to give an assurance that there's
no circulation that would be done in
conjunction with the CDC in the local
health department
there's also strategies that are still
needing to be validated but of pooling
samples on we know in some experimental
labs as many as 10 or 20 samples can be
pooled so essentially one test could
test 20 students and finally there are
some experimental approaches that look
interesting if not promising that for
example wastewater from an entire dorm
or an entire segment of a campus could
be tested to determine whether there's
coronavirus in that that sewage the
wastewater on so there are other
strategies being developed and I'd like
to at least give 20 seconds to dr.
Redfield who really will be working on
the strategy
how to employ this out giving different
community Fred dr. edsen yeah just some
quick climate sir I mean first I think
it's really important to evaluate
critically the role of changes in social
distancing on college campuses and and
schools in the situation not to forget
the importance of what we've learned
clearly also developing an aggressive
program for wellness education making
sure people understand when they're
symptomatic they need to seek evaluation
I think you are gonna have to look at
the role of testing I think there is
gonna be an important role of testing in
this circumstances and I I think it will
be individualized based on where these
different schools are where they how
much infection is in the I'm gonna wrap
it up there so I can set a good example
for the other senators were there five
minutes senator Murray thank you very
much mr. chairman and thank you to all
of our witnesses um dr. Falchi you have
warned a needless suffering and death if
we push to reopen too soon but the
president has actually been sending the
opposite message I want to ask you today
what is the most important message you
have for communities and states that are
reopening even as our public health
experts make it clear it's too soon tell
us what the consequences are thank you
very much for that question senator
Murray as I've said many times publicly
what we have worked out is a guideline
framework of how to safely open America
again and there are several checkpoints
of that with a gateway first
of showing depending on the dynamics of
an outbreak in a particular region state
city or area that would really determine
the speed and the pace with which one
does re-enter or reopen so my my word
has been and I've been very consistent
in this that I get concerned if you have
a situation with the dynamics of an
outbreak in an area as such that you are
not seeing that gradual over 14 day
decrease that would allow you to go to
phase one and then if you pass
the checkpoints of phase one go to Phase
two and phase three what I've expressed
then and again is my concern that if
some areas city-states or what-have-you
jump over those various checkpoints and
prematurely open up without having the
capability of being able to respond
effectively and efficiently my concern
is that we will start to see little
spikes that might turn into outbreaks so
therefore I have been being very clear
and my message to try to the best extent
possible to go by the guidelines which
have been very well thought out and very
well delineated so if a community or a
state the consequences could be pretty
dire correct the consequences could be
really uh serious particularly and this
is something that I think we also should
pay attention to that states even if
they're doing it at an appropriate pace
which many of them are and will namely a
pace that's commensurate with the
dynamics of the outbreak that they have
in place already the capability that
when there will be cases there is no
doubt even under the best of
circumstances when you pull back on
mitigation you will see some cases
appear it's the ability and the
capability of responding to those cases
with good identification isolation and
contact tracing will determine whether
you can continue to go forward as you
try to reopen America so it's not only
doing it at the appropriate time with
the appropriate constraints but having
in place the capability of responding
when the inevitable return of infections
occur well thank you for that and it's
very clear in order to do that we need
knowledge which is about testing and
promotes this administration's approach
to testing has really been plagued by
unrealized goals and disregard for
systemic problems within that supply
chain and last week an average of just
250,000 tests per day
were performed in the United States that
is a small fraction of what we need and
yesterday President Trump had the gall
to declare the u.s. had quote prevailed
on testing in a pressed press conference
that was filled with misinformation and
distortions dr. Gerard public health
experts do not think the US has
prevailed I'm glad you finally committed
that states including my home state of
Washington will receive enough tests to
meet their goals for May and June but
this administration has had a record of
giving us broken promises that more
tests and supplies are coming and they
don't and we don't know by the way the
testing is gonna needs will persist long
past you know so I wanted to ask you
today will the administration's
forthcoming strategic plan that is now
required under the Kovach package that
was just passed and signed into law will
that strategic plan on testing include
specific numeric targets for testing
capacity supply chain capacity and
projection of shortages thank you for
that question and in statement senator
Murray yes we are as I've stated we
continue to have a work in in progress
as we build the testing capacity we have
established the targets with the states
of over 12 million tests over the next
four weeks we think those targets are
going to be good in May in June but as
dr. Fauci said we really have to be
evidence-based we expect those targets
to go up as we progressively open as
communities go through phase one and
then into Phase two and certainly those
numbers will need to go up significantly
again in the fall when we potentially
have influenza circulating with with
kovat so yes there will be targets the
targets will need to change based on the
evidence that we see but we are highly
committed to securing the supply chain
we work daily with every manufacturer
and I'm just pleased we're in May and
June able to get ahead of the states so
that we can supply them what they need
so they have those assurances
any doubts about that to you is when you
put out that specific plan that you were
required to do we will see numbers that
you are going to tell us that you will
reach targeted for testing and supply
chain capacity and production of sorts
instead of just saying we hope to have a
million this week next week so you will
give us the specific targets correct we
know specifically I'll say yes ma'am we
know the specific we know the specific
amounts of tests we have over the over
the summer we have how many we need
so yes ma'am we developed the need
statement by working with the states
individually with epidemiologists with
the CDC so that overall in May will be
testing about 3.9 percent of the overall
US population not just for me but in the
coming months so that we can be prepared
to have yes ma'am and not to be
repetitive but um we need to be evidence
and data-driven because what what we may
see in May or June will drive
differences in the amount of test goals
we have so we we really just need to be
very humble about this we need to look
at the data we know that the testing
needs will go up over May and June as we
progressively open and we will do our
best to predict that but you have to
understand we have to see what the data
and the evidence show at that time okay
I appreciate that mr. chairman again
what our strategic plan requires is what
is the goal not how many we have but how
many we need and that's what we'll be
looking for thank you thank you senator
Murray senator Enzi Thank You mr.
chairman and I really appreciated your
opening statement where you had a very
succinct list of preparations we need to
learn from this endemic or the next one
I'd only should we be working on this
preparing but we and I think we've
learned a lot
we're fighting a virus at the same time
that scientists are learning about it so
we need to be nimble we also need to be
sure that we are prepared for
second wave of outbreaks it couldn't
coincide with the start of the flu
season potentially stressing our
healthcare system even more than it
already has Admiral drop I thank you for
your comments I think they've been
comforting about what has been done and
what can be done I agree with Senator
Murray that we have some specific goals
as an accountant that's always looking
for questions doctor dr. Hahn our
understanding of the clinical picture of
Oban 19 continues to evolve
what first looked like a respiratory
illness now seems much more
comprehensive potentially affecting the
heart the brain kidneys and other organs
how does this evolving picture impact
the ability to evaluate appropriate
clinical or surrogate endpoints for
review of vaccines and treatments Thank
You senator for that question the the
evolving clinical picture and obviously
the way this is manifesting around the
country clinically does in fact inform
the endpoints that we will work with
developers of therapies on so that we
can get the absolute most efficient but
also the most accurate information
inappropriate end points to make the
necessary authorizations and approvals
we have set up this program called the
corona virus treatment acceleration
program where our top scientists and
clinicians have been at the table
consulting with our colleagues at NIH
and CDC to actually address those
questions what are the appropriate
endpoints I'll give you an example we do
know that in some circumstances patients
who have had severe Kobe disease have
developed thrombotic for clotting type
episodes and so we prioritize a review
of agents that we think might be
beneficial and obviously the clinical
endpoints for those trials will be
different than an agent that's an
antiviral like Brenda severe where as
dr. Fauci mentioned we're looking at
time to recovery so we want to adapt it
to the
the clinical circumstance as well as to
the type of therapy that's put before us
thank you
another question to dr. Han we have made
a lot of progress in vaccine development
but Barda has identified that domestic
manufacturing of needles and syringes is
a significant gap in pandemic
preparedness
what has HHS done in advance eventual
national campaign to ensure that we have
sufficient has to be administered a
vaccine Cindy thank you for that
question
this is a really important point because
as you mentioned it's not just about the
vaccine or hopefully vaccines that are
developed it's all about it's also about
the supplies that are needed as well as
an operational plan for administering
the vaccine so this is an all of
government approach there is a program
that's been set up called Operation
warp-speed that includes dr. Collins dr.
Fauci his colleagues at NIH the
Department of Defense as well as other
members of HHS and FDA dr. Pierre marks
from our Center for Biological
evaluation research has been helping
coordinate that is working very closely
with dr. Fauci and his team and we've
created what's called a Gantt chart to
look forward what are the necessary
supply chain issues syringes needles etc
depending on the various vaccines that
are being developed how many times they
have to administer and the route of
administration so we've been leaning in
on this supply chain to ensure that when
a vaccine is ready to go we will have
the necessary supplies to actually
administer it not for a size the
vaccination thank you I have a couple
more questions but again the clock not
visible there's I'll submit those in
writing
Thank You Senator Enzi senator Sanders
thank you very much mr. chairman and let
me thank all of the panelists for the
hard work they are doing and for being
with us today it is sad to say that we
have a President of the United States
the leader of our country who from day
one downplayed the dangers facing this
country from the pandemic who told us
that the crisis would be over in a few
months that we did not have to worry who
fired those members of the government
who wanted to act aggressively in among
other things their time and we need
international cooperation cut funding
for the World Health Organization but
let me also say that I think we
understand that facts are terribly
important not everybody that we don't
fully understand all of the
ramifications of the kovat 19 epidemic
but let me a spot the facts a few
questions if I might for a start the
official statistic dr. pouchy is that
80,000 Americans have died from the
pandemic there are some epidemiologist
who suggests the number may be 50%
higher than that what do you think I'm
not sure senator Sanders if it's gonna
be 50% higher but most of us feel that
the number of deaths are likely higher
than that number because given the
situation particularly in New York City
when they were really strapped with a
very serious challenge to their health
care system that there may have been
people who died at home who did have a
Ovid who are not counted as colvin
because they never really got to the
hospital so in direct answer to your
question I think you are correct that
the number is likely higher I don't know
exactly what was that tire but almost
certainly it's higher doctor foul treat
let me ask you this in the terrible
or pandemic of 1918 the virus exploded
in the fall it came back with a
vengeance
are we fearful that if we don't get our
act together as bad as the situation is
now it could become worse in the fall or
winter a senator thank you for that
question it's a frequently asked
question and I think that a possibility
does exist however and the reason I say
that is that when you talk about will
this virus just disappear and as I said
publicly many times that is just not
gonna happen because it's such a highly
transmissible virus and even if we get
better control over the summer months it
is likely that there will be virus
somewhere in this on this planet that
will eventually get back to us so my
approach towards the possibility of a
rebound and a second wave in the fall
is that a it's entirely conceivable and
possible that it would happen but B I
would hope that between now and then
given the capability of doing the
testing that you've heard from Raja hua
and the ability of us to stock up on
personal protective equipment and the
work force that the CDC under dr.
Redfield will be putting forth to be
able to identify isolated contact trace
I hope that if we do have the threat of
a second way we will be able to deal
with it very effectively to prevent it
from becoming an outbreak not only worse
than now but much much less okay let me
ask we've heard a lot of discussion
about vaccines obviously everybody in
Congress and in this country wants a
vaccine we wanted as quickly as possible
as effective as possible oh let me ask
the Honorable FDA Commissioner sir uh if
God willing a vaccine is developed and
if we're able to produce it as quickly
as we all hope we can I would imagine
that that vaccine would be distributed
to all people
a free of charge we'll make sure at
least that everybody in America who
needs not vaccine will get it regardless
of their income is that a fair
assumption senator I I certainly hope so
FDA is very committed to making sure
that all populations in the United
States including those most vulnerable
are included in the clinical trials and
well that's that's not what I'm asking
what I'm asking is if and when the
vaccine comes it won't do
somebody any good if they don't get it
and if they have to pay a sum of money
for it in order to profit the drug
companies that will not be helpful are
you guaranteeing the American people
today that that vaccine will be
available to all people regardless of
their income sir the payment of vaccines
is not a responsibility of FDA I share
your concern that this needs to be
available to every American does anybody
else want to comment on that mr. Jarrah
you think we should make that vaccine
when hopefully it is created available
to all regardless of income what do you
think that poor people working people
should be last on line for the vaccine
I'm sorry senator were you asking me yes
yes I was no I my office is one of the
offices committed to serving the
underserved and we need to be absolutely
certain that if a vaccine or an
effective therapeutic or preventive is
available that it reaches all segments
of society regardless of their ability
to pay or any other social determinants
of health that there may be good so when
you're telling the American people today
that regardless of income every American
will be able to gain access to that
vaccine when it comes
they should have gained access to it I
don't control you know I think you
represent you represent an
administration that makes that decision
we advocate that everyone is able to
receive the vaccine regardless of income
or any other circumstance
let me just say I'm sorry all right
Thank You mr. Jenner those are important
questions I'm I don't want to catch
senators up but and it's hard to see the
the the time clock whether we could stay
as close as possible five minutes then
all senators can get their questions in
Thank You senator Sanders senator burr
Thank You mr. chairman and thank our
witnesses today for what you've done for
the people in this country and their
safety and people around the globe let
me ask you dr. Falchi because you've
been in the task force and at a majority
of the press conferences has anybody in
this administration ever asked you or
any member to take the foot off the gas
of trying to find a cure or or any type
of countermeasure no senator not at all
as a matter of fact we at NIH as you
know have been right from the very
beginning put off foot right on that
accelerator in every aspect including
the development of vaccines and
therapeutics and as I described my
opening statement we actually started
that in January literally days after
virus was known in its sequence was
published so no I have never been
followed by anyone to hold back on the
development of any countermeasure or any
basic and research project that we've
been involved in thank you dr. Powell
see this question is for dr. Redfield
dr. Redfield we have authorized in this
committee and appropriated out of
Congress multiple times over the last
few decades money for virus severe bio
severe Lintz and you talked about it in
the past 20 years from FY 16 to 20 it's
been 23 million dollars a year and with
the cures Act it's over a billion
dollars in bio surveillance
we've seen the private sector go out and
use data available to track the progress
and spread of corona virus around the
world
why is CDC not contracted with private
sector technology companies to try to
use their tools for bio surveillance
senator thank you for the question this
is a critical issue as you know and it
also comes into one of the core
capabilities I talked about data
analytics and data modernization which
we're appreciative of the additional
funding Congress has given I can tell
you that this is under a critical review
now we do have contracts with some of
the private sector groups now to try to
make the type of availability of data
that we've seen with Florida available
in all of our jurisdictions across the
country and and in the process of making
that happen dr. Redfield in April of
last year a June of last year we
reauthorized the pandemic and
all-hazards legislation which authorized
at that time 30 new billets 30 new
employees that CDC specifically in
surveillance now I asked dr. shooked in
March how many of those 30 had been
filled
she said zero as of mid-april zero of
those 30 billets had been filled how
many of those 30 employees that this
committee authorized CDC to bring on and
for biosurveillance have been filled
today sir again thank you for the
question I know our staffs have been in
discussion since dr. Schaack is
testimony and I know we're in the
process of continuing to try to figure
out how to move that forward sir I can
get back to you on it as I discuss what
progress has been made since we had that
discussion poster we're hearing with you
when you brought that delight well I
brought it to light the first March and
now we're in mid May so I'm hopeful that
we won't just talk about surveillance
will actually execute it and we'll focus
the unbelievable amounts of money that
we've provided for you that they will
show some some benefit to the American
people
dr. Fauci let me come back to you this
is one of the fastest development
timelines we've ever seen for vaccines
and the American people and hopefully
people around the world will be
beneficiary of what you what you find
and the eventual licensure of that
product what are the biggest unknowns
with this particular virus that can
affect the development process and dr.
Han if you've got anything to add after
that to this please do
dr. pouchy yeah thank you very much
senator burr well there are a couple of
things that I think are inherent in all
vaccine development first of all there's
no guarantee that the vaccine is
actually going to be effective as you
well know because we've discussed this
many times in the past and you can have
everything you think that's in place and
you don't induce the kind of immune
response that turns out to be protective
and durably protected so one the big
unknown is it will be effective given
the way the body responds to viruses of
this type I'm cautiously optimistic that
we will with one of the candidates get
an efficacy signal the other thing
that's an unknown that's of concern but
we'll be able to get around that by
doing the tests properly is that do you
get an enhancement effect namely there
have been none number of vaccines two in
particular dengue and respiratory
syncytial virus when the vaccine induces
a suboptimal response and when a person
gets exposed they actually have an
enhanced pathogenesis of the disease
which is always worry since we want to
make sure that that doesn't happen those
are the two major unknowns putting all
those things together senator Byrd
I still feel cautiously optimistic and
we will have a candidate that will give
some degree of efficacy hopefully a
percentage enough that will induce the
kind of herd immunity that would give a
protection to the population at all dr.
Han anything they add to that yes sir
thank you for the question the obstacles
from a regulatory point of view I think
are being met by the the approach that's
being taken out of HHS and led by Peter
marks and that is a common preclinical
development pathway so that we can
appropriately assess one vaccine against
the other and then a master protocol
that allows for a common control group
and an assessment to very common
endpoints that'll let us be as efficient
as possible for the development of
vaccine
a we will evaluate approximately 10
candidates preclinically and then in the
phase 1 and phase 2 studies and then
takes 4 to 5 into phase 3 studies in
this HHS effort so I think those are the
obstacles that can be broken down to
speed the development but also allow us
to ensure safety and effectiveness mr.
chairman yesterday the state of North
Carolina started to publicize the
recovered numbers those individuals who
have had corona virus but have recovered
it's my hope that nationally we will
start reporting the recovered numbers I
think that's important for the American
people to hear I yield back
Thank You senator burr senator Casey mr.
chairman thank you for the hearing as
well as ranking members Murray mr.
Chairman I wanted to start today with a
question regarding nursing homes in
particular across the state like ours
we've had as you might know a high
number of cases in Pennsylvania at last
count over 57,000 cases the number of
deaths have gone above 3700 and of
course a lot of those deaths are in
nursing homes we're told that nationally
more than a third as high as thirty five
percent of all deaths have been in
nursing homes either the death of a
resident of a nursing home or a worker
so I want to start with today with a
question for dr. Redfield doctor when
when we consider this challenge in our
in our long-term care facilities when we
look at the number of deaths and nursing
homes I think a lot of families want
basic transparency and that's one of the
reasons why Senator Wyden and I sent you
a letter dated April the 2nd it was
directed to you as well as the
administrator of the Centers on Medicare
Medicaid Services Seema Verma and in
that letter we asked for basic
information about what the
administration was doing to track the
outbreaks and nursing homes to provide
information
basic information to families in there
in and residents the the families of
residents in nursing homes shortly to
the workers as well as to the community
and public health professionals now it
took you over about a month to respond
to that but in your response you didn't
give us any information about the
timeline these families eat this
information and now we're told by the
CMS administrator after pressing errors
senator Wyden and I did that this
information may not be available until
the end of May I need to hear from you
today why is there been a delay a
three-month delay and basic information
that families and and people in it
within a community need about the
outbreaks in nursing homes the number of
cases what is happening in nursing homes
tell us when we're going to see that
information well thank you very much
senator and you've highlighted one of
the great tragedies that we've all
experienced together clearly the
long-term care facilities have been
particularly hard hit by this pandemic
several things I know that against Kim s
who has oversight several things have
been done and I can get back to you in
terms of where they're at in terms of
activation but clearly all nursing homes
now are required to report cases in
either their individuals that are
patients there or staff to the CDC um
secondly I have to put a policy in place
that all nursing homes are required to
notify members of that nursing home of
the existence of Ovid in that nursing
home include family members verify in
terms of when that's if that's
operational today or last week and I
will get back to you with that one of
the most important we have to
as we talk about key and reopening as
Tony mentioned we need it's symptomatic
cases we need to be do tack tracing but
the other thing that we really need to
do is to do surveillance because this
virus does appear to have a high
propensity for it's symptomatic
infection which means for traditional
ways to find cases is going to be
blunted and so we're developing a
national surveillance system and first
important is to do comprehensive
surveillance in all the nursing states
CDC will be doing that in partnership
with the state and local territorial
health departments
I think cursor is gonna have the
responsibility to do it within the
inner-city clinics that are selected in
Annie and health service for the Indian
Health Service clinics but this is
critical you get in front of this and to
comprehensive surveillance of everybody
in these nursing homes we've also done
you know aggressive outreach in all of
them and in enhancing infection control
procedures etc CDC's been out help these
nursing homes with that into the
guidance along with the CMS but I'll get
back to you in terms of the time I'm
pretty confident they're already its
operational but I need to double check
is to make sure because I know Seema has
announced that they're all reporting to
CDC now any infection in workers or
patients and that they are required now
to notify other members in the nursing
home as well as family members effect
mr. chairman just have one question for
dr. foxy doctor I wanted to ask you in
your testimony earlier in response to a
question by Senator Murray you outlined
a basic concern you have with regard to
states reopening can you restate that
for us yes thank you senator Casey yes
my concern is that a states or cities or
regions their attempt understandable to
get back to some form of normality
disregard to a greater place at the
the checkpoints that we put in our
guidelines but when it is safety seed
and pulling back on mitigation because I
feel if that occurs there is a real risk
that you will trigger an outbreak as you
may not be able to control which in fact
paradoxically will set you back not only
leading to some suffering and death that
could be avoided but could even set you
back on the road to trying to get
economic recovery but it would almost
turn the clock back rather than going
forward that is my major concern
sentient thank you thank you doctor mr.
chairman Thank You senator Casey Senator
Paul dr. Falchi scientists have shown
that rhesus monkeys that are infected
with kovat 19 cannot be reinfected
several studies have also shown that
plasma from recently infected
coronavirus patients neutralizes the
virus and lab experiments in addition
infusion of convalescent plasmas based
on the idea that recovering coronavirus
patients are developing in their feet
and that it can be beneficial as donated
studies show that the recovering kovat
19 patients from the asymptomatic to the
very sick are showing significant
antibody response studies show the
Tsar's and MERS also quota viruses
induce immunity for at least two to
three years and yet the media continues
to report that we have no evidence that
patients who survived coronavirus have
immunity I think actually the truth is
the opposite we have no evidence that
survivors of coronavirus don't have
immunity and a great deal of evidence to
suggest that they do the question of
immunity is linked to health policy and
that workers who have gained immunity
can be a strong part of our economic
recovery the silver lining to so many
infections in the meat processing
industry is that a large portion of
these workers now have immunity those
workers should be reassured that they
likely won't get it again instead of
being alarmed by media reports that
there is no evidence of immunity you've
stated publicly that you'd bet at all
that survivors of coronavirus have some
form of immunity
can you help set the record straight
that the scientific record as it's being
accumulated is supportive that infection
with coronavirus likely leads to some
form of immunity
dr. pouchy yep thank you for the
question Senator Paul yes you're correct
that I have said that given what we know
about the recovery from viruses such as
corona viruses in general or even any
infectious disease with very few
exceptions that when you have anybody
present it is very likely indicates a
degree of protection I think it's in the
semantics of how this is expressed when
you say has it been formally proven by
long-term natural history studies which
is the only way that you can prove one
is it protective which I said and would
repeat is likely that it is but also
what is the degree or titer of antibody
that gives you that critical level of
protection and what is the durability as
I've often said and I again repeat you
can make a reasonable assumption that it
would be protective but natural history
studies over a period of months
tewi years well then tell you
definitively if that's the case and I
think that's important because in all
likelihood is a good way of putting it
the vast majority of these people will
have immunity instead of saying there is
no evidence
you know the w-h-o kind of fed into this
by saying no evidence of immunity and in
reality there's every evidence stacking
up and in fact a lot of the different
studies have shown that it is very
unlikely to get it again in the short
term with regard to going back to school
one thing that was left out of that
discussion is mortality I mean shouldn't
we at least be discussing what the
mortality of children is this is for dr.
Falchi as well you know the mortality
between 0 and 18 in the New York data
approaches zero it's not going to be
absolutely zero but it almost approaches
zero between 18 and 45 the mortality in
New York was ten out of a hundred
thousand so really we do need to be
thinking about that we need to observe
with an open mind what went on in Sweden
where the kids kept going to school the
mortality per capita in Sweden is
actually less than France less than
Italy less in Spain
in Belgium less than the Netherlands
about the same as Switzerland but
basically I don't think there's anybody
arguing that what happened in Sweden is
an unacceptable result I think people
are intrigued by it and we should be I
don't think any of us are certain when
we do all these modeling's there have
been more people wrong with modelling
than right we're opening up a lot of
economies around the around the u.s. and
I hope that people who are predicting
doom and gloom and saying oh we can't do
this is going to be surged will admit
that they were wrong if there isn't a
surge because I think that's what's
going to happen in rural States we never
really reached any sort of pandemic
levels in Kentucky and other states we
have less deaths in Kentucky that we
have in us in an average flu season it's
not to say this isn't deadly but really
outside of New England we've had a
relatively benign course for this virus
nationwide and I think the one size fits
all that we're gonna have a national
strategy and nobody's gonna go to school
is kind of ridiculous we really ought to
be doing it school district by school
district and the power needs to be
dispersed because people make wrong
predictions and really the history of
this when we look back will be of wrong
prediction after wrong prediction after
wrong prediction starting with Ferguson
in England so I think we ought to have a
little bit of humility in our belief
that we know what's best for the economy
and as much as I respect you dr. Falchi
I don't think you're the end-all I don't
think you're the one person that gets to
make a decision we can listen to your
advice but there are people on the other
side saying there's not going to be a
surge and that we can safely open the
economy and the facts will to bear this
out but if we keep kids out of school
for another year what's gonna happen is
the poor and underprivileged kids who
don't have a parent that's able to teach
them at home are not gonna learn for a
full year and I think we got to look at
the Swedish model and we ought to look
at letting our kids get back to school I
think it's a huge mistake if we don't
open the schools in the fall thank you
mr. chairman can I respond to that even
though there are only 32 seconds left
yes and you might make it clear whether
or not you suggested that we shouldn't
go back to school in the fall well first
of all senator Paul thank you for your
comments I have never made myself out to
be the end-all and only voice of this
I'm a scientist
a physician and a public health official
I give advice according
they're the best scientific evidence
there are a number of other people who
come into that and give advice that are
more related to the things that you
spoke about about the need to get the
country back open again and economically
I don't give advice about economic
things I don't get advice about anything
other than public health so I wanted to
respond to that the second thing is that
you use the word we should be humble
about what we don't know and I think
that falls under the fact that we don't
know everything about this virus and we
really better be very careful
particularly when it comes to children
because the more and more we learn we're
seeing things about what this virus can
do that we didn't see from the studies
in China or in Europe for example right
now children presenting with Kovan 16
window covered 19 who actually have a
very strange inflammatory syndrome very
similar to Kawasaki syndrome I think we
better be careful if we are not Cavalier
in thinking that children are completely
immune the deleterious effects so again
you're right in the numbers that
children in general do much much better
than adults and the elderly and
particularly those with underlying
conditions but I am very careful and
hopefully humble in knowing that I don't
know everything about this disease and
that's why I'm very reserved in making
broad predictions
thank you thank you Senator Paul and
Senator Baldwin Thank You mr. chairman
and ranking member Murray and our
witnesses I want to cover a lot of
territory in my five minutes so I'd
certainly be appreciative of concise
answers but I want to start with dr.
Redfield direct field I think that the
testing protocols at the White House
presents a model for other essential
workplaces
I'm sorry senator you broke up at the
beginning of your question if you could
just say it again I'm sorry yes
dr. Redfield do you think that the
testing protocols currently in place in
the White House present a model for
other essential workplace
well I think well thank you for the
question I think one of the important
things you bring up is the essential
worker guidance at CDC put out and I
think it was originally modeled
obviously on health care workers where
there were significant health care
shortages individuals that works many
workplaces I'm asking if you think that
the White House protocols testing are a
model for other essential workplaces I I
would just say that I think each
workplace has to define their own
approach that's how to operationalize
our had some considerable comment on the
fact that OSHA has not stood up an
enforceable mandatory emergency
temporary standard for workers in all
sorts of work settings but that aside
would you say that the PPE rules and
protocols in effect right now in the
White House are a model for other
essential workplaces we would my own
view and would go back to the guidelines
that CDC has put out about central
workplaces for people if they are an
essential workforce that they go in
public they maintain six-feet distancing
in their way or face coverings okay you
are you have testified about how far you
come with regard to testing assessments
I want to ask you if you believe that we
already have a national testing strategy
today that spans that spans from the
nationwide testing needs assessment to
the nationwide testing supply assessment
and a strategy to fill that gap to from
here domestically what we need in terms
of bridging that gap with testing
platforms swabs specimen collection
media and reagents and the PPE
needed to conduct those tests so thank
you for that we do have a strategy that
bans us at least to the at least to the
fall on and beyond as I mentioned we're
working individually with every state
and I think that Senator Paul is correct
that Kentucky Wyoming or New Jersey
Rhode Island are different and there
there are vastly different testing needs
the East Coast will have multiples of
testing versus other states and we're
working those individually so I know you
testified earlier that not only are you
working with the states but you're
working with every lab in every state
increase capacity what about working
with those who would be the those who
would need testing to say reopen their
school their university their business
each of them have identified what they
think are their testing needs based on
you know guidance not mandatory
enforceable rules but are you in contact
at that level is your dashboard have
visibility at that lowest level or are
you mostly in contact with the states
and with the labs over the last few
months we've done a lot of the
individual work at nursing homes at
meatpacking plants that other I mean
really down to the very granular level
okay where we are right now however is
we are really working with the state
leadership with the Public Health lab
the state epidemiologist the shows the
state health officials on because they
they really need to understand what
their some is going to be in their state
and then in the fund in the funding
we're asking very specifically in the
CDC funding for specific plans for
schools nursing homes underserved
etcetera so I have two more points that
I'm going to make I don't have time for
questions one is about the transparency
of that needs assessment can the public
see it and the state see it can the help
committee members see it is it publicly
available and secondly the delivery of
this supply
is a critical issue and it seems to me
that the logistics are getting this out
whether it's PPE testing or medical
equipment is still extremely fragmented
leading to price gouging and many other
inefficiencies we need to stand up the
full power of the defense production Act
would you want me to comment on that
ma'am I'm sorry I'm happy to have you
comment it with the indulgence of the
Chairman we've gone over time and a
succinct answer to the senator please
decide when or why yes ma'am and yes sir
particularly for things like swabs and
media there is still a very I would say
non mature industry within the country
and that's why we've we've made the
decision to procure that all centrally
through December and that distribute
that to the state because they're just
too many small companies too many too
many variables to control without a
really heavy federal hand that's just an
example of where we really moved into
that and use the DPA for swab to help
support American industry on in more
mature aspects of the industry like some
of the large test producers we feel that
by helping direct them to make sure that
the states get what they needed the
right distribution that we're not
procuring them directly by us but again
we're going to be very evidence and
data-driven as we move on thank you sir
thank you very much senator Baldwin
senator Collins Thank You mr. chairman
let me begin by first thanking each of
our witnesses today for their expertise
their dedication and their hard work dr.
Redfield I want to start with you I am
hearing from Dennis all over the state
of Maine that the fad that they cannot
practice sinner
stayed despite following very strict
infection control protocols is causing
growing health problems Dennis tell me
that teeth with cavities that could have
been filled are now going to need root
canals teeth that could have been
treated with root canals are now going
to require extractions people with oral
cancers cannot get the treatment the
cleanings that they need before
beginning their treatment dental help is
clearly so important and maine state
officials as well as hygienists are
seeking assistance in reaching the right
decisions 47 other states either have
reopened dental practices or have a date
sent for them to reopen so my question
to you is this if dennis are following
the american dental association
guidelines if they're instituting strict
protective measures for their patients
their staffs their hygienists themselves
and if they're closely examining and
seeing a decline in the number of kovat
19 infections in their county are these
reasonable factors for states to
consider in reopening the practice of
Dentistry yes senator thank you for the
question you know we've been interacting
and talking with dentist and working
with the state and local public health
officials to update our guidelines on
reopening a variety of medical services
as you know and I think you raise a very
important point and I would would not
disagree with what you said about
looking at the American Dental
Association's
as well as the
the outbreak in the area but we are in
the process of updating those died lines
and they will include direct guidelines
for dental practices thank you very much
dr. dr. Jorah and dr. Han recently
there's been a significant man 4r mm
does safar I may be mispronouncing it
which transition to receiving an
emergency use authorization last week
mains 2 largest hospital systems
contacted me with questions about how
this therapeutic will be allocated going
forward
HHS finally released a statement on
Saturday about allocations going to
States interestingly not directly to
hospitals but once again the decision
making behind these allocations is very
unclear HHS and the assistant secretary
for preparedness and response say that
each state is expected to receive an
allocation but no timetable has been
provided beyond those who are being
treated with this drug at Maine Medical
Center through a clinical trial
I'm concerned that hospitalized patients
in Maine will have little or no ability
to be treated with this promising
therapeutic for the foreseeable future
as this and more therapeutics and
ultimately a vaccine come on to the
marketplace how can these allocation and
distribution is just be resolved so that
patient care is not delayed and so that
it doesn't depend on which state you
live in whether or not you're going to
get access to these treatments and
ultimately a vaccine
Senator Collins this oh good
Adams wrong go ahead commissioner
senator Collins I think we completely
agree with you that this has to be an
evidence-based approach getting the
medical therapeutics vaccines from deser
beer whichever it happens to be the
people in need I think we can all agree
upon the fact that we learned a lot of
lessons from your situation and of
course as you mentioned that's being led
by HHS and I'm an ass for what you've
seen the most recent announcement is
that what the task force did was provide
guidance to HHS regarding where the most
significant outbreak of hospitalization
outbreak occurred and where those
hospitals patient hospitalized patients
were this represented about a quarter of
the supply of drug that we have and more
will be allocated according to
methodology that gets drug to wear those
hospitalized patients are I think
valuable lessons can be learned and will
be learned with respect to other
therapies and to vaccines in particular
and we must incorporate those into our
operational plans moving forward thank
you doctor
Admiral do you have anything tat I'm
over time sorry thank you if you have
anything to add if you do so for the
record no ma'am no ma'am I agree with
the Commissioner it's it's absolutely
critical that it's evidence-based based
on the people who could benefit from it
and also fair and just throughout our
country thank you Collins and Senator
Murphy I thank you very much mr.
chairman thank you to you and Senator
Murray for convening this thank you to
all of our witnesses for your service
this is obviously an exceptional hearing
today and that three of our witnesses
are in quarantine and so I just want to
start by asking a pretty simple
yes-or-no question that I think I know
the answer to
dr. Fauci dr. Hahn dr. Redfield I'm
correct that all of you are drawing a
salary as you should
during your period of quarantine is that
correct senator let me let me start off
I think we better be careful about the
issue of quarantine we are essential
work is as part of the essential
infrastructure and we are when needed
which is often who our duties and
respect to places at the White House I
was at the White House yesterday and I
will likely even perhaps even be there
today
and in my office at the NIH so it is not
really strictly speaking the quarantine
as we know it but it is performing my
duties as critical workers and I'd be
happy to have my colleagues also respond
to that
senator Murphy this is a Steve Hahn I
agree with dr. Falchi yes I am drawing
salary and I have continued to work
during my quarantine and as an essential
worker will participate in meetings face
to face when that attendance is
considered critical my point here listen
you all should draw a salary well you
are taking precautionary steps because
of the contacts you have made my point
is that quarantine is relatively easy
for people like you and me we can still
work and get paid we can telework but
there are millions of other Americans
who work jobs that can't be performed
from home or are paid by the hour
and it's just remarkable to me that this
administration has not yet developed a
mechanism for states to implement and
pay for a quarantine system that will
work for all Americans your plan to
reopen America requires States develop
that plan and yet my state has no clue
how to implement and pay for that system
without help from the federal government
which leads me to my second question dr.
vouching dr. Redfield you've made news
today by warning us appropriately of the
dangers of States opening too early but
as Senator Murray mentioned this is
infuriating to many of us because it
comes hours after
president declared that we have
prevailed over coronavirus which I'm
just gonna tell you is going to make it
much harder on state leaders to keep
social distancing restrictions in place
it comes days after the president called
on citizens to liberate their states
from social distancing orders and I
think you're all noble public servants
but I worry that you're trying to have
it both ways you say this state
shouldn't open too early but then you
don't give us the resources to succeed
you work for a president who is frankly
undermining our efforts to comply with
the guidance that you've given us and
then the guidance that you have provided
is criminally vague and I want to ask my
last question on this topic um obviously
the plan to reopen America was meant to
be followed by more detailed nuanced
guidance right what is a downward
trajectory mean what happens if the
trajectory is downward in some settings
but upward in others what happens if you
reopen and then there's a spike in one
location or another setting and of
course you knew this because you
developed this guidance this this
additional guidance that is
site-specific that frankly is helpful
some of this is on the CDC website but
some of it is not and we need it my
state needs it we don't have all of the
experts that you have and so we rely on
you so reporting suggests dr. Redfield
that this guidance that was developed by
you and other experts was shelved by the
administration that it was withheld from
States in the public because of a
decision made by the White House so my
specific question is why didn't this
plan get released and if it is just
being reviewed when is it going to be
released because states are reopening
right now and we need this additional
guidance to make those decisions senator
I appreciate your question clearly we
have generated a series of guidances as
you know and is this outbreak response
has evolved from a CDC to an all of
government response as we work through
the guidances a number of them go for
interagency review and in every agency
input to make sure that these guidances
are more broadly applicable for
different parts of our society the
guidance is that you've talked about
have gone through that inter agents
review their comments that have come
back to CDC and I anticipate they'll go
back up into the task force for final
review
but before reopening in Connecticut in
five days in ten days I mean this
guidance isn't gonna be useful to us in
two weeks so is it this week is it next
week when are we gonna get this
expertise from the federal government
the other thing I will just say is that
the CDC stands by do you have technical
assistance do your state in any state uh
upon any request I do anticipate these
broader guidance though to be posted on
the CDC website that soon I can't tell
you soon but I can tell you your state
can reach out to CDC and will give
guidance directly to anyone in your
state on any circumstance that your
state desires guidance from soon isn't
terribly helpful Thank You mr. chairman
thank you senator Murphy senator Cassidy
hey gentlemen thank you very much for
your service and I will have a set of
questions so if your questions can be
brief I appreciate your answers can be
brief dr. Hahn in your testimony you
mentioned that the testing for the
populations and the vaccine trials now
includes over Americans I guess my
question though is what about children
does it include children does it also
include the obese the diabetic the
immunocompromised those who are at risk
of having a less non-response or
mitigated response to vaccination can
you comment on that please yes sir thank
you senator Cassidy when the phase 2
phase 3 trials are in place they will
include our most vulnerable populations
including the individuals that you
describe we're working very closely so
if I can interrupt phase 2 is normally
checked for safety you would not have to
do a separate phase 2 in the patient who
was younger
if I'm senator can you just assume the
safety data from the adults applies to
that of the children so no we we would
also want to assess safety sir as well
in children so the current phase two
trials do they include children they're
in phase one studies right now sir you
said we had a phase two going on well I
think it's about to start from the
modernity perhaps you can answer that
yeah I know senator Cassidy's no I know
I did not say a Phase two is I said we
are in a second dose of the phase one
and we will proceed when we finish with
phase one to go into Phase two so I
think I'm hearing that children will be
included in Phase two trials so that's
under discussion between FDA and NIH
this time sir because we do realize that
it's important for us to understand what
the C's and children but dr. Redfield to
build back upon 100 Murphy said the
published guidelines for schools at
school opening obviously you're about to
modify but I noticed as I read through
them there's nothing about testing so we
speak about testing targeted testing how
we use testing but the guidelines for
the school systems has nothing about how
to integrate testing will these be in
those guidelines that are being released
senator thanks for the question clearly
there's good need to be has already been
stated an integration of a testing
strategy that is going to be different
different school settings as well as
different jurisdictions whether setting
and that is going to have to be
integrated into each of those there's a
general overarching guidelines and then
as I say I do think detecting strategy
which is important is including the
surveillance strategy needs to be a
individualized let me come to that dr.
Redfield in all due respect I think
children whether you're rural frontier
suburban or urban is the one setting in
which there is a remarkable common
and I will echo what senator Murphy said
the resources that the federal
government has greatly exceeds all but
the most sophisticated populist wealthy
state and even then it exceeds it by
some extent so I do think it would be
good to have okay in a primary school
setting this is best practices or these
are three options and choose between one
of these three to say to each school
district or each private or parochial or
independent school work with your State
Board of Health figure it out
seems a wasted effort I say that because
children play such a role in both
protection of disease the spread of
disease etc so your thoughts on that
because it really seems that's the one
setting where you can have you know not
cookie cutter but certainly a pattern
which can be followed the senator I must
have been misunderstood when I was
talking about differences I was thinking
of the difference between an elementary
school a high school a college in terms
of how we a trade school there may be
differences on how you integrate a
testing strategy but I do think having a
testing strategy with different options
for people to evaluate based on
different principals will be important
in terms of guidance
dr. Falchi you persuasively argue that
the risk of reopening prematurely is
great but I think the frustration if I
think of children in particular the the
risk benefit ratio of a child being at
home potentially away from enhanced
nutrition without the parent able to
work because to school provides day care
without the monitoring as sometimes
occurs for incidences such as child
abuse but perhaps most importantly for
all children the opportunity cost of a
brain which is forming not having access
to the information that will help that
brain form optimally now as there have
been any sort of kind of risk benefit
ratio for the child yes they are at risk
for callous Aki's but they are a
particular risk for missing out on a
year of education particularly for those
from less than rich backgrounds I guess
I'm very concerned about that tension
what are your thoughts on that
now you
very good points Cassidy that may be
very difficult of the unintended
consequences of trying to do something
that broadly is important for the public
health and the risk of having a return
or a resurgence of an outbreak and the
unintended deleterious consequences of
having children out of school we fully
appreciate that I don't have an easy
answer to that III just don't just have
to sleep on a step-by-step basis as we
get into the the period of time with the
fall about reopening the schools exactly
where we will be in the dynamics of the
outbreak I might point out something
that I think has been alluded to
throughout some of the questions and we
have a very large country and the
dynamics of the outbreak on different in
different regions of the country so I
would imagine that situations regarding
school will be very different in one
region versus another so that it's not
gonna be universally or homogeneous but
I don't have a good explanation a
solution for the problem of what happens
when you close schools and it triggers a
cascade of events it could have some
common circumstances for I've mr.
chairman I'll close by asking permission
of the of the chair to submit for the
record an article that just came out in
the Journal of pediatric nursing
children are at risk from Ovid 19th B so
it'll be included Thank You senator
senator Warren thank you mister Thank
You mr. chairman and thank you to our
witnesses for being here today I hope
everybody staying safe and healthy in
the past 16 weeks over 1.3 million
Americans have been infected with corona
fires we now know that about 80,000
people have died and 33 million people
are out of work dr. Falchi you have
advised six residents you have battled
deadly viruses fear in their career so I
just like to hear your honest opinion we
have the corona virus contained
thank you for the question right now it
depends on what you mean by containment
if you think that we have it completely
under control
I mean if you look at the dynamics of
the outbreak we are seeing a diminution
of hospitalizations and infections in
some places such as in New York City
which has plateaued and starting to come
down New Orleans but in other parts of
the country we are seeing spikes so when
you look at the dynamics of new cases
even though some are coming down the the
curve looks flat with some slight coming
down so I think we're going in the right
direction but the right direction does
not mean we have by any means total
control of this outbreak so right
direction as I understand it we have
about 25,000 new infections a day and
over 2,000 deaths a day I think those
are the right numbers and some are
estimating we could be at 200,000 cases
a day by genes is that right dr. Falchi
I don't I don't foresee that as 200,000
new cases by June I am hoping and
looking at the dynamics of things
starting to flatten off and come down
that we will be much much better than
that just just so I understand we are
right now at 2,000 new infections again
a and to 25,000 new infections you take
and two thousand deaths again right and
that's where we are right now yeah yeah
yeah so let me just ask it we know that
it is possible to get this virus under
better control other countries have done
it like South Korea but we are now three
months into this pandemic and basically
we've continued to set records for the
number of people who are diagnosed and
the number of people who died
dr. Falchi you recently said that a
second wave of rotavirus in the fall was
quote inevitable but that if America
puts in place all of the countermeasures
that you need to address this we should
do reasonably well and the
countermeasures you identified are
things like
continued social distancing
significantly more testing widespread
contact tracing you also said that if
America doesn't do what it takes and
this is your quote we could be in for a
bad fall in a bad winter so right now
we're about sixteen weeks okay from
Labor Day that's about the same length
of time since the virus was first
detected here in the US don't you have
enough robust Helder measures in place
that we don't have to worry about a bad
fall and winter right now the projection
has you heard from Admiral hua with
regard the testing and other elements
that would be needed to respond the
projection is by the time we get to the
end of the summer and early fall and we
will have that in place and the
projection I get we don't have it in
place now but we are projecting that
will happen in place and let me just ask
the other side of this if we don't do
better on testing on contact tracing and
on social distancing we'll deaths from
coronavirus necessarily increase of
course if you do not do an adequate
response we will have the deleterious
consequence of more infections and more
deaths and that's the reason right you
quoted me senator quite correctly and
everything you said and I will stand by
that if we do not respond in an adequate
way when the fall comes given that it is
without a doubt that there will be
infections will be in the community and
we run the risk of having a resurgence
I would hope by that point in time in
the fall now we have more than enough to
respond adequate but if we don't there
will be problems
I appreciate your hope and I wish we
could tell the American people that the
federal government has this pandemic
under control but we can't in fact we've
said that the virus is not under control
in the US we haven't yet taken the
measures necessary to prove
a second wave of death and we all know
that the people who are going to be most
affected are going to be seniors
essential workers the people who are out
on the front lines the president needs
to stop pretending that if he just
ignores bad news it will go away it
won't
the time for magical thinking is over
here
president Trump must acknowledge that
the federal response has been sufficient
and that more people are dying as a
result we are running out of time to
save lives and we need now so thank you
dr. Fauci for all your doing
appreciate it but the urgency of the
moment not thank you Thank You senator
Warren senator Roberts thank you very
much mr. chairman and thanks to all the
witnesses you all are like the the Fab
Four I guess it was a Fab five back in
the day but we're shining the light of
truth in the darkness but the individual
flashlights for sure Thank You mr.
chairman for emphasizing that we have to
be bipartisan this approach we're not to
get anywhere and to that obviously is in
the eyes of the beholder I'm happy to
say that we have a very good
relationship Governor Kelly who happens
to be a Democrat obvious murder Pope and
her Emir to her emergency management is
spot on dr. Lee norm is doing enough job
that's the rest of this morning I talked
to Lee Scituate and Kant is a very good
I'm reading here Kandace receives
seventh the new covetous fork addicts
with food processing facilities you see
this mirror behind me that's the stage
boots coming into dodge' as opposed to
getting out of Dodge Dodge City is my
hometown BR the hot spot in regards to
Cantus mainly because of two packing
plants we have five
26% of the cattle mark at any grade
Candace is going through a tough time it
we shouldn't be worrying about their
safety of the food supply chain
I think nationwide is under a great deal
of stress we see that in dairy we see
that in poultry we see that in pork
their euthanizing pigs in office and
obviously the livestock industry sonny
Perdue with the Department of
Agriculture has stepped up so is the
president declaring that these packing
plants are a national asset we progress
city when we first started out had five
tests five
that's between four and six five it's
not 50 million as we hope to receive
that has been said by one of the
witnesses the reason I am really harping
on all of the problems were having an
act poacher on the fact that the
relationship of China is such that even
a first breakthrough with regards to
trade to China seems to be on hold on
and that's another price depressant then
this is going on five or six years where
our prices have been below the pasta
production end result our consumers are
really figuring out that food doesn't
come from grocery store and I'm very
worried that the harm to food value
chain is is very real not to mention the
financial situation that our farmers
ranchers and the growers all face now
having said all that I want to ask
Admiral Jorah you spoken about the
importance of having diversity in kinds
of tests that are available the five
packing plants we have in campus if we
could get a rapid test and we could get
it as we hopefully ask for because of
the hot spots that are developing not
only in Kansas but also doing great harm
for the food value chain that would be
absolutely wonderful would you speak to
that sir yes Thank You senator both dr.
red Phil and I have been very actively
involved in getting strategies or the
industry particularly in Kansas
um we are supplying very heavily the
public health labs with rapid
Diagnostics as well as surging them to
to areas like that so the one trade-off
however is that the rapid the quote
rapid point of care Diagnostics are very
slow so each machine can only do four
per hour and that's very very slow so
it's a mix of testing that you need at
these kinds of situations on sort of the
high throughput tests that are available
at a major lab a quest lab right there
in Kansas as well as a mix of the rapid
testing and that's what we're supplying
in order to provide a comprehensive
holistic solution and I believe CDC's on
the ground as well in Kansas supporting
that I appreciate that if you're only
doing for an hour that's not a rapid
test maybe it's a rapid slow test I'm
not quite sure how you define that but I
for one think that as we reopen and by
the way governor Kelley started the
opening process first of this month on
this may 18 and then we go to June and
then the hope is we hope not but we do
have contingency plans that if that
doesn't work as aptly described by
doctor pouchy I think we'll be right but
this is going to be a tough go I have to
tell you that in terms of Agriculture
we're not in good shape I appreciate
everybody and the job that you were
doing will stand beside you when you're
taking the booze and behind you when
you're taking files Thank You senator
Roberts senator Kaine Thank You mr.
chair to the committee leadership and
witnesses for calling this important
hearing the last time doctor foul Qi and
Hahn were before us was March 3 I have a
slide that I want to put up that shows
what's happened in America since then
the chart which is here compares the
experience of the United States in South
Korea on three days On January 21 both
nations experienced their first case of
Kovan 19 at that time the unemployment
rates in both countries were essentially
I don't
on March 3 when the witnesses were last
here South Korea had experienced 28
covin 19 deaths in the u.s. eight
experienced nine again the economies of
both nations is measured by the
unemployment rates were nearly identical
but now the story changes as of
yesterday more than 81 thousand
Americans have died and the US economy
has experienced job losses not seen
since the Great Depression
meanwhile the economy of South Korea has
not changed dramatically at all and the
death toll is now at 256 South Korea is
smaller than the United States one-sixth
of our population but even if you bulk
up the death toll to reflect the
difference the per capita death toll in
the u.s. is more than forty five times
the rate in South Korea and the
healthcare carnage here is causing a
near depression while South Korea has
protected its economy by managing
correctly I could have done this chart
with other nations the US has the
seventh highest per capita death rate in
the world our death rate is off the
charts higher than that in India
Australia New Zealand Japan and Mexico
it's nearly three times the death rate
in Germany twice as high as Canada's
rate the question is why if we want to
open up our economy in schools we have
to learn the lessons of nations that
have managed this well here are some
things that don't explain the difference
our hospitals are as good or better than
those in South Korea our health care
providers heroes are as good or better
than those in South Korea our research
capacity is as good or better than South
that in South Korea and we have more
resources than South Korea our GDP is 12
times
South Korea's and our per capita income
is 50% higher so to dr. pouchy the death
roll in the United States the death rate
in the United States especially when
compared with other nations is
unacceptable isn't it sorry sir
yes of course I mean a death rate that
high is something in any matter of form
in my mind is unacceptable and dr.
Falchi the experience of other nations
shows that the u.s. death rate is not
only unacceptable but it's unnecessary
isn't that correct
I don't I I don't know if we can say
that but would you say that the US has
to do better of course you always have
to do better I mean that's a and and the
experience of South Korea shows that how
a nation manages the healthcare crisis
has a huge impact also it's an on it's
economic condition isn't that the case
that is the case sir I understand where
you're going with this but I have to
tell you there was a big difference
between South Korea and the United
States the outbreak and let and let me
again let me get to that I want to get
to factors that do explain the
difference since we know it's not
resources or our health providers first
is testing South Korea began began
aggressive testing much earlier than the
u.s. now in the fifth month of the
pandemic we surpassed South Korea in per
capita testing but in the critical month
of March South Korea was testing its
population at a rate of 40 times the
testing in the US
Admiral Gerard dr. Gerard has set out
the standard for us when we get to
September he says the United States
needs to do 40 to 50 million tests a
month to be safe that equates to about
1.3 million to 1.7 million tests a day
yesterday we did 395 thousand tests
we've got a long way to go a second
factor is contract race contact tracing
South Korea embraced a rigorous contact
tracing program right from the beginning
the United States still has not engaged
in a national contract tack tracing
program isn't that right with that by
dr. pouches dr. Redfield so I think that
question would best be directed to the
CDC when the outbreak started - sir we
had an aggressive contact tracing
program
unfortunately as the cases rose it went
beyond the capacity and we want the
mitigation so we lost the the
containment is clearly and that was key
to the economy as well because South
Korea did testing contact tracing
protect serve isolate the sick and then
they didn't have to do the shutdowns
which helped their economy social
distancing is a third factor we've
talked about it but finally the last one
healthcare systems would you agree with
me that it helps keep people safer
either from serious conditions or death
from Kovan 19 if they have access to
healthcare yes of course of course
of course that's the case in South Korea
ninety seven percent of the population
have health insurance in the United
States before kovin nineteen millions
didn't have it and lacked access to
health care the massive job losses in
the last month's threatened to take
health insurance away from millions more
and President Trump is doing all he can
to dismantle the Affordable Care Act
which would take health insurance away
from tens of millions more let's learn
the lessons from those who are doing
this right Thank You mr. chair I yield
back
clarification please mr. chairman this
is up breath sure why I just wanted to
clarify that I did project that we will
have the ability to perform 40 to 50
million tests per month in in that
timeframe but I said if needed that that
at that time I am NOT making a
proclamation we have to really
understand what where the epidemic is
what the community spread is before we
can ask to make the number of tests that
are needed
I was simply stating the fact that our
combination of testing capabilities will
be at that level even barring on new
input from the NIH thank you very much
senator Kaine senator muskie Thank You
mr. chairman and gentlemen thank you for
being here this morning ritually but
also for all you have been doing for
these many many months
Alaska's doing ok right now from a
numbers perspective and quite honestly
we want to keep it that way because we
know we have exceptionally vulnerable
populations we know we have a geography
that is challenging we
that we have facilities that are very
limited last hearing we had an
opportunity to hear from dr. Collins and
he shared where they are with the red X
and also spoke to red X up which was
very interesting about what we can be
doing in rural areas but but focusing on
hotspots and as I reminded him we don't
want to be a hot spot in Alaska so every
effort that we make to keep the virus
out of of Alaska is our lives that are
saved I him on the community of Cordova
that is just getting ready to open it's
it's a Copper River salmon fishery in
two days and was able to share that they
had had one worker tested positive as he
was coming in from the lower 48 to come
to work the good news on that is that
all the protocols that we have put in
place seemed to be working the
quarantine the isolation not only for
that individual but for others that he
had come in contact were secured so I
want I want to recognize the assistance
that we have received from the
administration dr. Eastman is in the
state at this moment the the chief
medical officer for the Department of
Homeland Security going out to rural
communities to really better understand
our our vulnerabilities go to some of
our fishing communities to again
understand how we can successfully
prosecute a fisheries when you have to
bring workers in from the outside we
thank you for the assistance with
regards to additional testing capacity
I've been in in contact with our chief
medical officer the state this morning
and the mayor of Cordova just better
understanding again do we have the tests
that we need what do we need on the
ground and one of the things that that I
would like to have clarified and this is
probably to you dr. Shu Alchemy's
because you have been so helpful in kind
of shining the light on what we need to
be doing in these rural areas but so
much of the focus has been on hot spots
and responding to the hot spots
but how do you keep those rural remote
small communities from becoming the
hotspots in the first place are we doing
enough and right now the strategy has
been we just lock it off the travel
restrictions that are in place are
apparently working but they're also
they're also devastating our economy
whether it's tourism whether it's our
resource industries or whether it's the
potential for our fisheries so Admiral
if you might speak to to that aspect of
it and then I have a very important
question as it relates to contract
contact tracing that I'd like to direct
to either Admiral yaw or dr. Redfield so
Thank You senator and as you know you
have an outstanding State Health Officer
and dr. Anne zinc and we do I've had the
privilege of working with her and you
have a very good protocol in trying to
keep Alaska safe by isolation over a
period of time when you come in as you
know we also work with the state to meet
your your very challenging testing
requirements because you can't really
you know then last out a thousand miles
away so we put a real customized mix to
point-of-care and also the Cepheid
machines I think we sent nine or ten new
to Alaska and about 50,000 tests which
is about four times than you've done to
date collectively in order to provide
that support so again I do think there's
a comprehensive strategy that you do
have but again the mitigation is to the
degree that you can given the the
circumstances the face maps the
hand-washing the hygiene we understand
fully the challenges particularly in the
fishing river environment and the remote
but all these have to come together the
testing the tracing the mitigation the
hygiene factors to try to keep your
community safe and we really understand
culturally that many of your communities
were almost annihilated in
1918 influenza pandemic so in that
memory is still very sharp and very
hurtful to many of the citizens though
we want to do our best to assure them
that we're giving them all the
protection we can let me let me turn to
dr. Redfield because this relates to
contact tracing I think this is a very
very key part of how we move forward
into getting people back to work getting
people back to school right now we have
about a hundred people that are involved
in contact tracing in Alaska that's
clearly not sufficient there's been talk
about a national strategy but I think we
recognize that we have teams in place
whether it's America or whether it's
Peace Corps whether it's our our public
health corps what more do we need to be
doing to make sure that once you've been
tested positive you know then what
happens after that who else needs to be
brought into into this and I'm not
convinced that we're focusing enough on
that aspect of how we move to to
reopening if we haven't done the contact
tracing thank you very much senator I
want to just reinforce what you said I
think contact tracing capabilities is
critical it's going to be the difference
from succeeding in in containing this
outbreak from once again using wide
scale community transmission or not
we're positioned as you know to deploy
redeployed the number of CDC over 500
CDC individuals we have another about
650 that you're trying to put into our
foundation but most importantly we're
trying to work with your health
department with the resources that we've
been able to give because of the
Congress mentals also as you mentioned
with these other agencies with LabCorp I
mean with America work with the Census
Bureau to work together and have the
state develop they're using capacity
some states have reacted state work some
states of Riya in a National Guard while
they begin to do this but I agree with
you and I said it's going to be
and they see a significant effort to
build the contact capacity that we need
in this Nate state-by-state but it's
gonna need to be augmented properly in
your state from what you just said fold
and we're there to work with the states
to help them with the Cobblers that
needs to get in place before September
here we need to move on it thank you
Thank You senator Murkowski I don't want
to any senator off but we have eight
more senators we have five minute rounds
and and it's 12:30 so I'd like to
request that the Senators and the
witnesses succinct questions and try to
stay within five minutes would be
appreciated
senator NASA well thank you mr. chair
thank you and the ranking member for
having this hearing and thank you to our
witnesses today and please pass our
thanks along to all of the hard-working
women and men in your agencies who I
know have been working virtually around
the clock to try to improve our response
and keep Americans safe and mr. chair I
hope you and all the witnesses are
healthy and safe today as is everybody
on your team I wanted to start by echo
in the comments my colleagues have made
about eating leadership from the CDC and
our public health experts on how we are
going to use facts and evidence as
guidance so that our schools and our
daycares and our businesses have the
information they need to create safe and
sustainable plans to reopen and of
course that means too that our testing
capacity not only has to be enough but
it has to be flexible enough to meet our
needs the key distinction between South
Korea and the United States is not how
many tests per capita over a certain
amount of time we've done but the fact
that at the onset of this pandemic South
Korea was much more able to do a lot
more tests per capita than we were and
then follow that with all the other
measures you've talked about so that we
continue to need to identify the knee
and then build our capacity towards the
need not the other way around I wanted
to start with a question to you dr.
pouchy first of all thank you for your
work and your expertise I wanted to talk
about nursing homes for a minute in New
Hampshire and across the country
a huge number of the deaths from koban
19 that we are seeing have been in
nursing homes we all know people who
have lost a friend or a family member in
nursing homes and the brief compounded
by the fact that people couldn't be at
the loved ones Benson died if they died
yesterday dr. Burks said that all 1
million nursing home residents should be
tested within the next two weeks as well
as all nursing home staff dr. pouchy as
a short-term goal that makes sense to me
but after that what will the ongoing
federal recommendations look like how
frequently do we need to test patients
and staff on a continuing basis and what
other measures will be necessary to keep
our loved ones in these facilities safe
thank you for the question of Cigna
hassen the the general plan as you
mentioned that was recommended by dr.
Burke's is a sound plan as you said in
the immediate question is in the long
range we will have to have infection
control capabilities in nursing homes
that are really pristine and it really
unassailable we have to do the kinds of
surveillances and have to have the
capability of when you identify someone
you get out of that particular
environment so that they don't spread
the infection throughout so general
testing for all I think is a good start
but when you look where are you gonna go
in the future it has to be a
considerable degree of surveillance
capability thank you doctor the White
House is now requiring all staff to wear
masks and anyone in regular contact with
the president tested daily do you think
nursing homes should implement those
same measures to help make sure that our
seniors can get the same level of
protection I think there should be a
system in place the optimal protection
of people in nursing
and that would be necessarily testing
every person every day that's one
approach that might not be practical
when you think of all the nursing homes
in the country but strict regulations
and guidelines about who is allowed to
go into the nursing home and the staff I
believe needs to be monitored very
carefully with intermittent testing to
make sure that we don't have
introduction into the nursing home of
infected individuals I'm not sure you
can practically do it testing every day
that I don't think would be feasible but
something that is much more aggressive
than has been in the past I believe
should be done well thank you I have one
last question for dr. fudd she and dr.
Redfield I would also just say that if
we are able to get masks to everybody in
the White House I hope we can get masks
to every nursing home employee needs it
dr. Falchi and dr. Redfield the US needs
to be preparing now to ensure that we
have a stack sure and administer
vaccines something you've both touched
on both for an eventual koban 19 vaccine
as well as other illnesses such as the
flu the failure to ramp up production of
testing and personal protective
equipment early on during this crisis
made things worse here that those
mistakes can't be repeated when it comes
to vaccine production and distribution
we are already seeing reports that some
children are not receiving routine music
immunizations as it becomes more
difficult to access in person care
doctor pouchy what steps should we take
now to ensure that we have sufficient
manufacturing and distribution capacity
or a cope at 19 vaccine without putting
at risk our capacity manufacture and
distribute other important products such
as Apple or measles vaccine and my
follow-up question to dr. Redfield would
be what efforts are underway at CDC to
ensure that all routine vaccines are
accessible during the Cova 19 public
health emergency yeah thank you for that
question said it has no answer as
quickly as possible I alluded to this in
my introductory remarks when I was
talking about vaccines for coping 19 and
what we said that as we do the testing
on these
scenes we are gonna make production at
risk which means we will start putting
hundreds of millions of dollars of
federal government money into the
development and production of vaccine
doses before we even know it works see
that when we do and I hope we will and I
have cautious optimism that we will
ultimately get an effective and safe
vaccine now we will have doses available
to everyone who needs it in the United
States and you can contribute to thee
what is the needs globally because we
are partnering with a number of other
countries the other part of your
question about making sure that when we
get into a situation like the so called
shutdown that we might be and now then
we make sure that children get the
vaccinations that they need because that
would be an unintended consequence of
shutting down as we are right now it's a
very good point we want to make sure we
don't fall behind on that also thank you
thank you very much and I'll take my
answer from dr. Redfield offline thank
you so much for allowing me to go Thank
You senator hasson senator Scott Thank
You mr. chairman into the panel thank
you all for being here virtually without
any question we find ourselves in the
situation that we wish we were not I'm
very thankful for folks like dr. Burks
dr. Fauci and many others for your
dedication 24/7 without any question our
nation is safer because of your hard
work I want to direct my questions
towards dr. Fauci really one specific
question dr. Fauci and I'm thinking
about the reopening of America and
specifically the reopening of South
Carolina and I'm taking into
consideration the fact that in South
Carolina I think overall our cases are
moving in the right direction we have a
little less than 8,000 cases
unfortunately 350 deaths our hospital
capacity is actually better now than it
was when the pandemic started our
ability to isolate hot spots and
mitigate the spread of the virus is I
think where it needs to be with that in
mind I flew into Washington from South
Carolina yesterday we have plans to test
additionally 220,000 more residents by
the end of this month focusing on
at-risk populations by the end of this
month we will have tested 100% 100% of
nursing home residents and the staff
that takes care of them and after
increasing our contact tracing work
force twenty fold in the matter of weeks
our state's Health Department announced
yesterday that we're going to increase
it by an additional 1,400 contact
tracers we have built and we continue to
build the tools necessary to better
detect and isolate cases to map their
exposure and to prevent substantial
spikes moving forward most importantly
our health care system thanks to in part
to flexibilities from this
administration has the beds and the
equipment necessary to address the most
serious cases when they arise now with
these tools in hand we have begun to
reopen to be clear we continue to
scale-up testing and to make to take
measure to protect the most vulnerable
and the data points are increasingly
clear for older Americans and for those
with chronic conditions like diabetes
and high blood pressure
this virus remains a threat a dangerous
threat a recent report suggests that in
New York roughly 90% of the fatalities
had underlying issues two-thirds of
fatalities were 70 years or older 95
percent over the age of 50 in South
Carolina the meeting age of patients who
have died from the virus
seventy six and a half nearly two-thirds
of fatalities have been patients older
than 71 and nearly 90% were over the age
of 60 and roughly 98% in South Carolina
are over the age of 50 contrast that
with those aged 20 and younger where
we've seen no deaths fewer than 1% of
deaths in my state have been under the
age of 40 every single death is a
tragedy every single one and we mourn
what our family members have lost their
loved ones weird
every measure to protect our older South
Carolinians as well as those with
underlying conditions but we set out to
flatten the curve by taking aggressive
unprecedented measures like staying at
home orders and mass small business
closures we didn't set out with the goal
of preventing 100% fatalities that would
be unrealistic
it is impossible and we didn't set out
to keep quarantines in place until we
found a safe and effective vaccine that
would take too long dr. Redfield your
agency put out a helpful graphic showing
two curves one respite quickly and Pete
high reflected daily cases without
protective measures the other flatter
curve showed cases with those measures
in place and the whole point which the
graphic Illustrated was to make sure
that we did not exceed hospital capacity
so while I respect the need for caution
we are too often presented with a false
dichotomy either saving our economy are
saving lives we've seen the goal posts
around flattening the curve move and I
think that's unfortunate because at the
same time we're doing that business is
to the collapsed mental and physical
health have declined depths of despair
escalate education outcomes nosedive as
we wait in our living rooms praying for
some good news
around therapies and around vaccines we
said I'll to flatten the curve and I
think we've done a pretty good job with
that we need to do better and we will do
better my question dr. Fauci is as we
start the process of moving towards
reopening South Carolina what else would
you suggest that we could do to protect
our most vulnerable populations Thank
You senator Scott you gave a really very
eloquent description of what I think is
one a would be a model way the way
you've approached this I mean you have
put things in place that I think would
optimize your capability of real
and I was as I was thinking as you were
speaking I almost want to clone that and
make sure other people hear about that
and see what you've been doing the issue
of your direct question to me about the
vulnerable populations is that as we
have said in our guidelines and I looks
like you were ready to progress
carefully because you put into place a
very good system that the vulnerables
the elderly and those with underlying
conditions should be those who at the
very last listing of mitigations should
be those who are left in a situation
where they might be in danger of getting
infected in other words protect them
right up until the very end of the
relaxation of your mitigation because as
you said very correctly those are the
individuals now the most vulnerable so
the morbidity and the mortality so those
are individuals particularly I might say
sir those in Demon's already grew the
african-american and Hispanics who for a
variety of situations that are the
social determinants of health have a
greater likelihood of not only getting
infected but of also having the
underlying conditions that would make
their risk for a high degree in
morbidity mortality higher so it looks
like you're doing things very very well
and I would encourage you to continue
and to follow the guidelines as you get
closer to normalizing your state thank
you thank you dr. falchion I'll just
simply close with this since I'm out of
time thank you for the many
conversations that you and I have had
about those vulnerable populations to
include minorities as well as our senior
citizens I will say that without any
question when you look at nursing homes
as typically african-americans and
Hispanics are the certified nursing
assistants who are providing care for
the elderly population so your focus on
those two very vulnerable groups is much
appreciated and thank you for your
expertise Thank You senator Scott and
Senator Smith thank you so much
Alexander for your service dr. Fauci I
have to say you're in the unenviable
position
being a person that so many Americans
and Minnesotans trust to give us the
straight scoop and tell us what's really
happening you're about the facts and not
about the politics and that's a really
good thing simply I have to start by
asking a question that I think a lot of
a lot of Americans want to know which is
how are you doing how are you believable
I'm doing fine senator thank you very
much for asking this is this is such an
important problem it transcends all of
us individually and has to be working as
a team and and I enjoy very much working
with your senators and the governors
because it's at the local level that
we're gonna make this thing works I'm
fine I appreciate your concern well a
lot of people are thinking about you and
are grateful for your service as we are
for all of you you know so we're
gathered today to think about what we
need to do to reopen our economy and I
think first about what's happening in my
home state of Minnesota where
agriculture is such an important part of
how our state works it's a part of our
history in our pork processors right now
are looking at the reality of using
thousands of hogs a day because there is
no place to process them because of
what's happening into processing plants
and the working people who do the hard
work and those processing plants are
getting sick so here's one story this is
one worker the Star Tribune wrote about
this named hamari DeJesus
she's an asylum seeker and a mom who
works for a contractor that does the
cleaning in the processing plants and
she works for $14 an hour seven hours a
day five days a week
and her job is to sanitize the machines
that process the the meat into a ground
meat and she started feeling sick on
April 11th but she kept going to work
and on April 21st when one of her
co-workers fainted she told her
supervisor that she felt sick and so she
was told to go home but that if she
didn't show any signs of illness she
should come back she went to the doctor
and she paid a hundred and fifteen
dollars
get a test and found out a few days
later that she was Co but positive and
she's still at home she's still she's
not getting paid and she doesn't have
health insurance and nearly two weeks
ago
president Trump deployed the defense
production act to keep these processing
plants open but the USDA gave really
limited guidance about what would be
safe for those workers it said for
example in response to testing which has
been such a big part of what we've been
talking about today they said this is a
quote facilities should consider the
appropriate role of testing in workplace
contact tracing of koban 19 positive
workers in a worksite and assessment so
dr. Fauci as we think about how we move
forward we all want to open up the
economy what what guidance would you
give us in a situation like this here in
Minnesota well I can give you my
common-sense guidance although this is
not the area of my expertise it's more
in others but it would seem that if you
want to keep things like acting plants
open that you've really got to provide
the optimum degree of protection for the
work is involved the ability to allow
them to go to work safely and if and
when individuals get infected to
immediately be able to get them out and
given the proper care so I would think
when you're calling upon people to
perform essential services
you really have almost amaro
responsibility to make sure they are
well taken care of and well protected
and again that's not an official
proclamation that's just me speaking as
a physician and as a human being thank
you doctor ouchy and I think that you
speak as a human being but you also
speak as the chief epidemiologist of our
country and the person that we all trust
and this is the point that I want to
make and drive home with everybody which
is this is the kind of guidance that you
should be getting and following and then
this is the kind of these are the tools
that we we have got to have in our
country if we are going to reopen our
economy as we all want to do and
if we move forward with reopening our
economy and yet we still have
circumstances like we have in these
processing plants and in other places
around the state we are going to be
we're gonna be right back where we
started and except even in a worse place
as I think you pointed out dr. bhaji
Thank You senator and and again it
really does relate to one of the
questions that one of your colleagues
senators asked me before that one of the
things that I keep emphasizing and I'll
just repeat it again because it's
important that when you are in the
process of opening up and pulling back
on mitigation you really must have in
place the capability of responding when
you do have the inevitable upticks in
cases that will absolutely occur it's
how we deal with it and how successful
we are in putting the clamps on it that
will prevent us from getting the kind of
rebound that not only from the
standpoint of illness and death would be
something that's unacceptable but it
will set us back in our progress so it's
reopening the country thank you very
much senator Smith
senator Romney this hearing at the
participants in it I'm going to take off
work senator house I understand that
politicians are gonna frame data
politically of course they don't expect
that from Admirals but yesterday you
celebrated that we had done more tests
and more tests per capita even than
South Korea but you ignored the fact
that they accomplished theirs at the
beginning of the outbreak while we
treaded water during February and March
and as a result by March 6 the US had
completed just 2,000 tests whereas South
Korea had conducted more than a hundred
and forty thousand tests so partially as
a result of that they have 256 deaths
and we have almost 80,000 deaths
I find our testing record nothing to
celebrate whatsoever
the fact is their test numbers are going
down down down down now because they
don't have the kind of outbreak we have
harder going up
they have to I think that's an important
lesson for us as we think about the
future on a separate topic my impression
is that with regards to vaccines that
were I'm critical of what we've done on
testing on vaccines we've done a pretty
darn good job moving ahead pretty
aggressively and yet the president said
the other day that President Obama is
responsible for our lack of a vaccine he
add dr. Fauci is President Obama or by
extension President Trump if they do
something that that made the likelihood
of creating a vaccine less likely are
either President Trump or President
Obama responsible for the fact that we
don't have a vaccine now or in delaying
it as someone in some way
no no senator not not at all certainly
President Obama nor President Trump are
responsible for not having a vaccine we
moved as you said because I described it
in my opening statement rather rapidly
no one has ever gone from knowing what
the virus was to amaze one trial as fast
as we've done so I don't think that's
something that once you say anybody's
responsible for doing anything wrong on
that I think that's right
that's the correct way to do it thank
you there that was my impression I was
surprised by the comment but that was my
impression dr. Redfield a sender cinema
and I wrote a letter to you expressing
our dismay at the lack of real-time data
at the CDC I'm talking about granular
demographic hospitalization treatment
data how is it possible in this day and
age that the CDC has never established
such a real-time system with accurate
data and and what can Congress do to
rectify that so we never have to look at
something like this again
oh there you go sorry senator thanks for
the question I think you've hit one of
the important they are the first one I
focus on is data data modernization data
analytics and predictive data analysis
clearly Congress has forward in
providing funding for a data
modernization and we are in the process
of implemented there the reality is
there there's an archaic system a not
integrated public health system each
Public Health Department has their own
systems this nation needs a modern
highly capable a data analytic system
that can do predictive analysis I think
it's one of the many shortcomings that
have been identified as we went through
this outbreak and I couldn't agree with
you more it's time to get that corrected
thank you please help guide us as to
what we need to do to make sure that
happens that I presume it's not filled
at ourselves but work with companies
that have that capacity and use that
capacity in our favorite doctor thought
you won one last thing which relates to
a virus and I I know I'm asking you the
impossible question but we're all hoping
for a vaccine obviously it's the
objective of our administration to get
it as soon as they can and from what I
can tell they're pulling out all the
stops to do exactly that given our
history with vaccine creation for other
coronaviruses how likely is it I mean is
it extremely likely we're going to get a
vaccine within a year or two is it just
more likely than not or is it kind of a
long shot it's definitely not a long
shot Senator Romney I would think that
it is more likely than not that we will
because this is a virus that induces an
immune response that people recover the
overwhelming majority of people recover
from this virus although there is good
morbidity and mortality at a level in
certain populations
the very fact that the body is capable
of spontaneously clearing the virus
tells me
and at least from a conceptual
standpoint we can stimulate the body
with a vaccine that would induce a
similar response so although there's no
guarantee I think it clearly much more
likely than not that's somewhere within
that time frame we will get a vaccine
for this virus Thank You mr. chairman I
yield Thank You Senator Romney I want to
thank the witnesses for their patience
we have four more senators and we'd like
to give them a chance to ask their
questions so senator Jones thank you
very very much mr. chairman and thanks
to all our witnesses for your being here
virtually and also for your incredible
service during this time I want to
follow up real quick with a an
additional statistic that Senator Romney
talked about with regard to South Korea
and that is the fact that you're a
nation that has about six times the
population of South Korea but yet we
have about 310 times the number of
deaths from this pandemic so I think we
have to be very careful in making
comparisons around the world
comparing the United States to other
countries dr. Redfield I want to follow
up just a little bit with what Senator
Murkowski and I think senator Kaine
talked a little bit about contact
tracing and where we're going I
understand you are working with States
to try to develop plans for reopening
the testing is important the contact
tracing is important but using that data
as well is also going to be important in
terms of quarantine plans that Senator
Murphy talked about child care
facilities to have allow people to put
their kids in a facility while they are
still go back to work all of those
issues including maybe even facilities
like vacant hotels or motels that may be
used for self isolation how is this plan
being developed within the CDC is are
those plans going to be individualized
by state will we as a member of Congress
be access to those plans and how how our
state's going to pay for these and I
think that because my state's already
using the money that we've already given
them as a wishlist I mean they're
talking about building
a million dollar Statehouse as opposed
to developing the test and doing the
contact tracing so I'd like to three
just to drill down a little bit on how
these plans are going to develop what
access we will have to have those plans
and be able to see them thank you very
much senator this is obviously said
before there's a critical component of
us take this time to become how to get
prepared for next fall winter and
building that comprehensive contact
racing capacity we're working
individually with the leadership of the
state health department's the local
departments territorial tribal to try to
let them get asked to understand what
they think their capacity needs are and
those discussions have already happens
that motor are said there's been a
variety of federal H together on testing
and contact tracing CDC's in position
that we've reprogrammed our individuals
that we have across the country we're
500 begin to help each of these states
we've amended that with some additional
personnel that we're green on board
state by state foundation we've the
money that Congress has appropriated
into the states so they can begin to
start thinking about how do they want to
return contact tracing capability and
then of course it was mentioned that
we're other government programs like
AmeriCorps
this is Peace Corps so that each group
is going to extract their contact
tracing piece what they think their
needs are and I do think it is gonna be
similar to what we heard from the
senator from South Carolina these are
significant increases he said he
incredibly fold anything that they're
gonna increase again but the point you
brought up is so critically important
and we found that as we already
struggled through the repatriation of
different Americans from around the
country where we had to put many of
these in quarantine as you know using
military bases because many of the state
and local health department's really
developed a system where do they put
somebody who
be an isolation who's homeless how do
you develop the system so this has to be
part of it too is it there's there
certain a city that's intrinsic for
hotels as you mentioned the point that
was made by one of the other senators is
so important about individuals that
particular like they the Meatpacking
individual that has to go home and self
isolate but maybe I have ability don't
go home and so if I sleek and I'm up to
general generation analyst with about 12
other people mechanisms to be brought in
we have an effective way identify cases
don't like X and then do the appropriate
public health measure and these have to
be comprehensive it's gonna be developed
on jurisdiction that at a time I seek no
reason why these are not transparent
documents as they get get completed and
it really is a tribute to what the
congressional support that you've given
so far as I said one point six billion
dollars got into the state and then
again to do this in addition of the
resources that we've gotten but it is
fundamental people underestimate how
important it is we have a highly
functional comprehensive aggressive
attack you seen program so that in the
next to this outbreak we contain them we
don't have to switch or mitigation right
thank you thank you dr. Redfield
preciate it it sounds to me like we
still got a lot of work to do so thank
you thank you very much senator Jones
senator broad Thank You chairman been so
much discussion about testing in general
listen to Senator Romney earlier I think
Senator Kaine mentioned it everybody has
dr. Han if you remember when we first
met I said is the FDA going to be more
entrepreneurial is the FDA going to kind
of not be estado talking then about how
we fix the health care system in general
now this has brought it into clear focus
I've got a timeline that I'm gonna
submit for the record it shows from
January 24th
through March 5th and I want to
emphasize what senator Burr asked
earlier has the administration ever put
an impediment in front of trying to get
to testing and dr. Hahn this will end up
in a question in a moment but there was
a span of time from January 24th through
March 5th that I hope the American
public looks at and it gets back to
what's wrong with our health care system
in general early testing from what I'm
seeing was created by the fact that the
CDC said it was going to do its own
tests the South Korean test that gets
cited so often was not going to be
looked at we had to do our own I know
the FDA worked with the CDC but the long
and short of all of this is that for
nearly a month this was in that
bureaucratic swirl the FDA prevented
private and academic development of
tests for weeks
the CDC decide denied access to
functioning tests as I cited in South
Korea this created through all the red
tape and bureaucracy to where we had to
come up with a one-size-fits-all
approach due to the uncertainty of the
virus and we are stuck with that now I
don't want to dwell on that necessarily
because I think those are mistakes that
we made I'm tired of having it heard
that it's the administration's fault dr.
Hahn I'd like to ask you this question
in that spirit of what we talked about
during your nomination process here
going forward will we shed some of that
stodgy nough swell we look to get
therapeutics and vaccines through the
system in a quicker method because I
fear if we don't and if we treat through
bureaucracy how we did the early period
of testing we can be labor this into the
distant future and at that point there
there's gonna be not only the carnage
from the disease itself but from the
economy to deal with so I'd like your
comment on that one month stretch what
accountability the FDA and the CDC have
and then whether it looks better in
terms of moving more quickly into the
future us Thank You senator Braun for
the question our timeline of that period
demonstrates that we began working with
test developers beyond CDC on January
24th and had double-digit number of test
developers working with us one of the
issues that we identified was in fact
availability of the virus and other
supplies to actually get that test
development done in a timely fashion
senator I completely agree with you that
this is an opportunity for us to take a
look and determine how we can do things
better and I think that's a really
important thing for all of us to do and
certainly the FDA I can promise you will
do that
looking forward sir I can commit to you
that we will look at every one of our
regulatory authorities we have done so
during this outbreak we have provided
significant flexibility and have tried
to provide the right balance between
regulatory flexibility and enabling of
the great test developers and
therapeutic developers in this country
with the need to ensure that our gold
standard of safety and advocacy is in
place we have leaned in with
manufacturers we've learned a lot from
them as well as the other stakeholders
and we will continue to learn and we
will I commit you sir implement the
changes that are necessary to make sure
that we can act in a more simple way but
still protect the safety and efficacy of
medical products thank you doctor foul
Qi taking a page from your anti-aids
playbook then implemented a formal
clearly defined treatment review pathway
can we do that
for kovin 19 in a similar parallel track
that you put into place
back then in the 90s in fact I've got a
bill called the promising pathways act
that is based upon that protocol you put
into place
can we do that two more quickly get
through to therapeutics and vaccines
herewith kovin 19 well it's it's a
different story but some similarities if
you're referring to the parallel track
that I put into place back in the in the
late 80s which was when there was no
availability of drugs at all for HIV and
when we were testing drugs within a
protocol that we would make it available
outside of the protocol in what has
ultimately turned out to be
compassionate use so what we did is we
didn't want to interfere with the
integrity of the protocol to determine
in a control way what was safe and what
was effective but there was a dire need
for some sort of accessibility to those
drugs outside of a clinical trial for
those who might even have some chance of
having it and in fact that was really in
many respects the birth of the really
firm concept of compassionate use and in
fact there is a version of that which
I'll hand over to Commissioner on that
is you know when you have expanded
access and emergency use authorization
but drugs that have not yet been fully
proven in a clinical trial so there is
somewhat of an analogy and similarity
between what I did in the 1980s and what
is actually being done on the FDA now so
Steve if you might want to comment on
that I think that's right
dr. Falchi the emergency use
authorization process by statute allows
us to have flexibility and assess the
risk benefit ratio and a public health
emergency and we've done that on the
therapeutic side in three separate
occasions and continue to look at those
requests as they come in thank you very
much you Thank You senator Braun senator
Rosen here I am
Thank You mr. chairman for bringing this
hearing and I want to thank the
dedicated doctors today for their
lifetime of work and study and passion
we are a grateful nation for all of your
your lifelong commitment in fighting
disease and not just the United States
but around the world and you know as I
talked to Nevadans about safely
reopening the economy one question that
frequently comes up is when are we gonna
have a vaccine like everyone's talked
about and Nevada travel and tourism of
course to life but for us and the jobs
associated with those industries can
only fully come back if we know it's
safe to travel and visit our work at our
hotels casinos restaurants and
attractions ultimately to make this
happen we have to build confidence in
our visitors and it's safe we need a
vaccine and that research is extremely
important however understanding that
this takes time to develop and sure and
ensure both safety and efficacy I'd like
to hear more about what research is
happening regarding preventive
medication research it could be helpful
in the timeframe before a vaccine and
especially before one is widely
available so I'd like to ask if this
could be part of the path helping us
begin to reopen our economy safely and
bring visitors not only back to Nevada
but across our country so doctor pouchy
what research is currently happening to
identify potential monoclonal antibody
preventative treatments or other
therapeutics if the right antibody is
identified or can be identified
would this be used as a preventative
medication to block Kovan 19 virus from
latching onto those host cells
much like the treatments for rheumatoid
arthritis severe asthma or other
diseases and secondly would preventive
medication options like this complement
the effectiveness of X of a vaccine once
it's available yes so thank you for that
question senator Rosen that's an
excellent question and in all of the
therapeutic interventions that we are
developing and you mentioned several of
them they could
be direct antivirals along the line of
REM disappear but that's just an one of
a number of possibilities since there
are several viral targets in the
ratification cycle using convalescent
plasma and a preventive modality as well
as monoclonal antibodies in a preventive
modality are in fact all feasible and
will be pursued in parallel with the
development of a vaccine the model using
drugs and other interventions that are
effective is really a great success
story in the issue in hiv/aids because
many of the interventions that were
developed for the full treatment of an
infected person are exquisitely
effective in preventing infection of HIV
so that's the kind of model that we work
out in parallel with treatment for
disease it's the using as treatment as
prevention I believe that will be a part
of our effort at the same time as we're
putting a full-court press on trying to
get a vaccine so it's an excellent
question very relevant I know I have a
hard time left so I'm just gonna kind of
abbreviate this the second most
important question that I get not just
from our first responders are people
worried about heart but generally what
does the next generation of PPE need to
look like for all of us as we go about
our lives not just as workers it
depending on your work you may need
something stronger or more specific as
all of us as we want to go out with shop
or out to eat or whatever those things
are getting on an airplane should mass
be made of a certain material gloves or
handkerchiefs effective can you talk
about PPE for the general public well
you know the best PPE for the general
public if possible right now is to
maintain the physical and social
distancing but as we've said and I think
all of us would agree there are certain
circumstances in which it is beyond your
control when you need to do necessary
things like go to the drugstore and get
you vacation go to the grocery store and
get your food
that in fact you need some
supplementation to just physical
distancing that's the reason why some
time ago the recommendation was made I
believe it was dr. Redfield at the CDC
who first said that about getting some
sort of a covering we we don't want to
call it a mass because back then we were
concerned we would be taking masks away
from the health care providers but some
sort of masks like facial covering I
think for the time being should be a
very regular part of how we prevent the
spread of infection and in fact the more
and more as you go outside right here
and where I'm sitting in Washington DC
you can see many people out there with
masks on which gives me some degree of
comfort that people are taking this very
seriously thank you
cutes Rosen senator Leffler thank you
all for being here and for your service
Admiral Jerrod before I start my
questions I want to recognize your new
role as the US Representative to the
World Health Organization mitigating a
resurgence of this pandemic will take
global cooperation in order to do that
we need accountability and transparency
at the w-h-o this organization was
established to ensure the timely flow of
accurate unbiased information on global
health emergencies just as this
performance reforms must be made in
order to restore the trust that we need
here I hope you'll work with our allies
to push for these reforms this question
I have two questions the first one is
for dr. Redfield and and dr. Redfield
Georgians are wondering how we got here
today 1,400 deaths a third of Georgia's
workforce out of work
I'm incredibly concerned about the
cover-up and the misinformation coming
from China and their efforts to suppress
life-saving information at the outset of
this outbreak as we can sit as we
continue to reopen our economy safely we
have to take steps to ensure that
another outbreak cannot take
hold of the world in this way I
understand CDC has worked with the
Chinese CDC on global health security
for decades can you comment on the level
and the timing of the information that
you received and relied upon from your
Chinese counterparts as this virus
emerged well thank you very much senator
and I want to echo how important global
house security is a national security
priority for this nation and we're gonna
need to be able to be able to respond to
that as long as we are a nation CDC has
had relationships with countries around
the world we have offices and over 45
countries right now people on over 60
and one of those happens to be China
where we have a US CDC that's with the
Chinese CDC we've worked together for
four decades particularly on influenza
and emerging infectious diseases and
that has been a very productive
collaborative scientific scientific
interaction when this original outbreak
of pneumonia of unknown etiology came
from the original seafood market
obviously discussions with US personnel
that being with Chinese CDC I personally
had discussions as early I think CDC did
is anywhere and myself can you Airy
third with the counterpart discuss this
scientific level the broader Chinese
government level
thank you dr. Redfield I have a final
question for each of our great witnesses
today and it's one that my constituents
often ask me the mainstream media and
indeed some of my colleagues in the
Senate seemed to want to paint each of
your relationships with our president
during this wartime effort is
confrontational and lacking consensus
can you categorically say here to the
American people today whether this is
true or untrue from your testimony today
I've seen a very coordinated effort
to address this with the administration
to combat this pandemic can you give me
a sense of whether this character is
what the characterization Israel is
whether it's true or untrue thank you
I'd ask dr. Fauci to answer that first
yes no there is certainly not a
confrontational relationship between me
and the president
as I mentioned many times I give advice
opinion based on evidence-based
scientific information hears that he
respects it he gets opinions from a
variety of other people but in no way in
my experience over the last several
months has there been any
confrontational relationship between us
thank you dr. Redfield dr. Hahn again at
but echo with dr. Koch you said then
we're there to give our best public
health device and that's what we do and
rounded end date in science and I've
always felt free to give the best public
health advice that I think needs to be
given at the time and it's always been
done in a very professional level
Senator Lafleur this is Steve Hahn I do
not have a confrontational relationship
relationship for the president he asks
questions I have given him my honest
answer is rooted in data in science and
then he's listened respectfully to those
incorporating that into his
decision-making and Brett sure why I
have nothing else but to echo my
colleagues we work very closely together
on all the scientists all the physicians
of course ambassador birx other
scientists within our group we have a
very productive working relationship
with each other and also with the
president and vice president
it would not be confrontational and I
certainly feel that we have the ability
to honestly state our opinions and
recommendation and that's been that way
since the beginning Thank You senator
Leffler
do you have closing comments aye I do
and if it's already I have a couple of
two quick questions
sure well thank you you know dr. pouchy
well president Trump there is no
question that an essential part of
reopening our economy safely is
successfully developing and distributing
a vaccine for Koba 19 we need to plan
now to deploy a vaccine once it's proven
safe and effective but it is absolutely
crucial this planning process from the
clinical trial to distribution and
administration recognizes and addresses
racial and ethnic disparities in our
healthcare system that as we all know
for too long have been overlooked and
unacknowledged in this country and we
have to ensure equitable access access
to this vaccine for everyone dr. Fauci
let me start with you what steps is NIH
taking to make sure that clinical trials
for kovin 19 back to vaccines and
therapeutics account for racial and
ethnic disparities yeah thank you very
much that's a very relevant question
senator Murray and in fact in the design
of our clinical trials and the sites
that we've chosen in our clinical trial
Network it's going to be very
representative of being able to get
minority populations and pate and
populations at the most risk to be part
of the trial so that we know during the
trial what the relative efficacy as well
as potential adverse events is something
we started back in the days of HIV when
we tried to get good demographic
representation and we're going to do
that with these guys thank you thank you
and dr. Horne
tell me what steps FDA is taking now to
make sure the United States is prepared
to produce a sufficient number of
vaccines including the necessary
manufacturing supply chain capacity for
supplies like viola stoppers and
syringes Thank You senator this is an
effort that started as a partnership
with the vaccine developers and the NIH
and their efforts so one of the most
important things ma'am has been the data
transparency sharing of data
both of the agency NIH and with the
manufacturers so we can understand what
the capacities are what the needs are
from the supply chain and then how to
actually share that so that if one
manufactures vaccine doesn't go forward
we can use the capacity of that
manufacturer for another manufacturers
vaccine I'm very happy and report that
the work of dr. marks inductive ouchies
has led to that sort of effort we are
we've developed as I mentioned before
this Gantt chart that describes all the
steps that go forward with vaccination
including those supplies you describe it
is somewhat complicated ma'am and that
we may very well have hopefully five to
seven different candidate vaccines that
may need different supplies associated
with them but we've been upfront
identifying no supplies where they're
available and then working with the
manufacturers to make sure that they are
available okay thank you thank you very
much mr. chairman thank you and thank
you for all of our witnesses for joining
us today it is really clear to me that
we have more work to do before we can
safely get back to work and school and
some semblance of normal life in our
country we still need testing to be fast
free and everywhere and we need the
White House to lay out a detailed
national plan to make that happen we
still need adequate personal protective
equipment both for our healthcare
workers and for workers and our
businesses and at schools when the time
comes we still need guidance from our
experts
so our communities have the information
that they need to reopen schools and
businesses safely confidentially
confidently and complete competently and
so public health workers and health care
providers have the information they need
to keep their patients and communities
safe and while experts have been clear
that the day we can safely be often may
be a ways off there's plenty for us to
do in the meantime goes to plan ahead
for example to make sure that once we
have a safe and effective vaccine we can
produce and distribute it to everyone
quickly equitably at no cost and to
address the immediate challenges for
example making sure there are
appropriate mental health
resources for everyone who's coping with
the challenges that are prevented
presented by this virus from the stress
of physical isolation loss of income to
the trauma and anxiety of patients and
workers who've been on the front lines
so I'm gonna keep pressing Congress and
the White House to provide the action
and leadership that our communities need
and I hope mr. chairman that we'll
continue to have the opportunities like
this hear directly from the experts and
ask pressing questions about how to get
our country through this crisis it's
clear we've got a lot further to go a
lot more to do and so I hope that as our
efforts continue we'll be able to
breathe if any of you that our witnesses
for another hearing soon and again thank
you to all of you for joining us today
thank you senator Murray I've got a
clarification question and a couple of
quick comments and then we'll well thank
the witnesses and wind up hearing my
clarification is I want to make sure I
didn't create some confusion by the way
I asked the question about going back to
school I asked dr. Fauci first about
treatments and vaccines and dr. Admiral
jalaw second about testing what I
thought I heard was that dr. Fauci said
that vaccines are coming as fast as they
ever have but it'll it'll be later in
the year at the earliest before we see
that there's some treatment some of that
that have that are modest whether
promising there could be more but that
that doesn't mean you shouldn't go back
to school that that that would be more
or testing strategy am I right dr. Fauci
you didn't you didn't say you shouldn't
go back to school because we were all
dead nothing absolutely not mr. chairman
what I what I was referring to is that
going back to school would be more in
the realm of knowing the landscape of
infection with regard to testing and as
Admiral Joss said it would depend on the
dynamics of the outbreak in the region
where the school is but I did not mean
to imply at all any relationship between
the availability of a vaccine and
treatment and
you go back to school you're quite
correct and what I heard from Admiral
Jerrod was that you're ramping up
current technologies you are hopeful for
dr. Carlin dr. Collins shark tank and
the National Institutes of Health but in
any event you would expect to have the
capacity in the fall of 40 to 50 million
tests a month and that ought to be
adequate for the principal of a middle
school or even the chancellor of a
campus to divine design a testing
strategy that could provide for example
a an antigen quick yes to screen all the
students in the school and necessary
that correct yes sir mr. chairman and
again we want to make as many tests
available as as absolutely possible
what I what I said is what I feel
comfortable with knowing the production
schedules being in the position of being
able to work with the FDA and CDC that
we should have 40 to 50 we will have 40
to 50 million tests available per month
that need to be deployed in a smart
strategic way depending on the dynamics
you know in that area in in that region
I'm still having testing even widely
does not nullify the need that we're
going to have to change our practices in
terms of sanitation personal cleanliness
distance seeing face masks things like
that given what the dynamics could be
well thank you for those comments
because given the given that number of
tests that will be available in say
three months or as we ramped up to that
number three months from now that should
give every principal every every every
Chancellor of every college campus and
again we have about 5,000 campuses and a
hundred thousand schools a some
reassurance that testing as well as the
common sense hygiene practices you
talked about could be used to develop a
strategy for reopening school for school
in August and then two quick comments
one is Senator Murray talked about the
national plan which was in the
legislation that we all voted for
there's a little bit of a push and tug
between what's national or what's
federal what Washington should do and
what the states should do
I've always thought it's a mistake to
say federal equals national in other
words over 19 is clearly a national
problem but that doesn't mean the
federal government's supposed to do
everything for example in testing the
law actually requires States tell you
Admiral draw what their plans are what
their needs are and then you said that
during the month of May you had a series
of state plans that identified 12 and a
half million yes and you thought you
could help meet that on the other hand
you've also noticed an efficiency in the
marketplace for some supplies so the
federal government is buying those and
allocating them to the state so we don't
want to get in a situation where
everyone's our law is telling all the
states what to do governor leads in
Tennessee doesn't really want you to
tell him what to do he wants to tell you
what he's doing and let you comment on
it I don't think Governor Cuomo wants
President Trump telling him what to do
so a pushing tug between what Washington
does and what the states do I think we
have a testing contact tracing isolating
national strategy and plan led by the
governor's designed by the federal
government as a national effort another
national effort clearly is to do the
research for the treatments and the
vaccines of what we've heard today is
that's coming along on a faster track
than we've ever seen that we're seeing
before finally I want to reiterate I
thought this was a very helpful hearing
I think the Senators for their questions
I think anybody who took the time the
watch would be impressed by the
diversity of opinion and the honest
answers we got from four really
remarkable experts who are in the midst
of this every day I want to resize what
I said earlier that I intend to make
sure that we focus senator murray
suggested we need to have more hearings
I agree with her and
we deal with this pandemic we need to
make sure we're ready for the next one
what can we learn about faster
treatments and vaccines for the next
month what can we learn about the
stockpile well to be in it you ought to
be managing for the next one what can we
learn can we learn anything about having
hospital beds so we don't have to shut
down hospitals and bankrupt them and
patients out in order to create beds for
sick people from the pandemic what about
States and hospitals that sell off their
PPE in between pandemics how do we keep
our focus in between pandemics when
we're have so many important things to
be worried about this country how do we
make sure that we in Congress sustain
and fund all the things that we need to
do so and I want to make sure that we do
that this year I mean we our collective
memory is short so while we're all
worried about this we need to not only
deal with this crisis but get ready for
the next I thank the witnesses for their
extra time I hope they get a sense that
our job we see is to create an
environment in which you can succeed
because if you succeed our country
succeeds which is what we desperately
want the hearing record will remain open
for 10 days members may submit
additional information for the record
within that time if they would like
thanks to everyone for being here today
hearing is adjourned thank you very much
mr. chairman thank you senator Murray
you